Sorry, we were waiting a minute.
She had to put on a spaceship.
Oh yeah, it was all me.
All me.
Yeah, it was all me.
I have my space suit on.
Yeah, while we were waiting, Nimi sent us a very...
Hey, it was from the steam pane.
Right off the steam pane.
Oh, I see what's happening in that picture.
I just was focused on the sentence.
I didn't even see it.
Oh.
Oh, Nimi was like, I didn't... Oh.
I see, I see.
It's that type of game.
Yeah, it's that kind of game.
Yeah, you just gotta help a brother out, you know.
We'll see if that happens to any of us.
Yeah.
What a way to go, you know.
What a way to die.
This is some people's real fantasy, though.
Yeah, honestly it is.
It's the first thing that goes.
Wait, where did you find this?
On the Steam page?
Yeah, it's on... No, it's on the...
It's on the official Steam page for the game.
Oh, yeah, but you guys know where it is.
I'll show.
Yeah, I'll show.
Some people thought it was amazing.
I'll show it too.
I'll put it on the screen for the...
This is for the class.
Here you go, everybody.
Why don't you share the class?
Share it in the class.
Nimi, why don't you...
I'm sharing it.
I...
I take no responsibility for this image.
This was...
Posted for everyone to see on the...
On the Steam page.
It was out in the public.
This is why Doki chose this game.
Yeah, yeah.
I saw this...
I saw that...
That specific image.
I was like...
Damn.
The perfect game.
I wonder why he died.
Yeah.
Weak.
That's all I'll say.
Weak?
Anyway.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to...
To the green-yellow collab.
Yay!
Team green!
Let's go green!
Let's go yellow!
Yellow!
We all have a little bit of green on us.
Yeah, and we all have a little bit of yellow on us, too.
Wait, that's true!
Yeah.
Cohesion.
We're really actually cohesive.
Oh, yeah, we do.
The green-yellow woman.
The lobby clothes.
Oh, did it?
We're all still here.
Oh, yeah.
Come back!
Okay, gosh.
I was like...
Hey, come back to us, Doobie!
Come back!
Come back to space!
Hold on.
She landed back on Earth.
She had...
I got ejected.
I got voted out.
Oh, yeah.
You got voted out.
Gotta do your tasks.
Yeah, someone was not doing their tasks.
Why didn't you fix the lights when it was off, Doobie?
Hi!
I'm busy looking at an image, really.
Yeah, yeah.
He looks good.
That's the one.
You got distracted.
I think that makes Nimi the most size.
Oh, that's true!
Don't vote me out!
I don't know what I'm doing!
I've never played the game before!
I like this story!
Excuses!
Yeah, none of us have played the game before!
What are you talking about?
Yeah, actually...
Do we know what kind of game this is?
Um...
It's basically...
Actually, no.
I mean, it's like one of those proximity chat horror co-op games, right?
You know what's funny?
I suggested the game, too.
I was like, um...
No.
I just know we're exploring the moon.
It's like...
We're trying...
Oh, wait, no.
We're trying to find the moon.
And return alive.
So it's like a friend swap.
Trying to find the moon?
Yeah.
We lost the moon?
Oh, yeah.
It did say something like that.
You have to find the moon.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
How could...
Oh, my gosh.
Gru did it.
He fucking did it.
He stole...
He stole the moon.
And we're trying to find it back.
We're just little minions.
My steam is offline.
I gotta fix it.
Oh, no.
Take your time.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Take your time.
But it's not Tuesday.
Oh.
Is it Tuesday?
I'm really...
No, no.
It's Friday.
It's definitely Friday.
Yeah.
Happy Friday.
Yay.
Happy Friday, everybody.
Happy Friday, everyone.
Happy Friday.
Okay.
Also, Soundgat.
My...
For people who are, like, wondering about the sound.
We're gonna be using the in-game VC.
But, like, the lobby VC is so quiet.
Yeah.
We gotta, like, get in-game and kind of fix it.
But we sound like we're in space, though.
That's the best part.
We sound like we're actually in our little spacesuits.
That's, like, Xbox mic.
It really is.
It is.
I'm gonna get on there.
I'm gonna be, like, a ten-year-old.
I'm gonna cuss you out.
No.
John Madden.
You frickin' dummy.
All right.
You're gonna get banned for that kind of language.
Oh, that's true.
I will hurt you.
Gabe is looking right now.
Oh, no.
John Madden.
She's...
Sucking.
That video, apparently, is, like, 15-plus years old.
And it's still fun.
Still got it.
Every, like, couple of months, I think about it.
Oh, no.
All right.
Doob... Oh, wait.
Is Steam still down for you, Doobie?
Um...
It was up.
Like, I closed it and then I relaunched it and then I connected.
But now I'm disconnected again.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
Oh, it was working.
Sorry.
It's okay.
It's all right.
We're bonding.
Yeah.
We're having a little bonding session before we betray each other in space.
Oh, is it that the game?
There's no rules in space, Batman.
Oh, man.
Is PvP enabled?
Is PvP a thing?
I was like, is it even a thing?
I don't know.
I mean, can we fight the monsters or no?
I mean...
I hope so.
We can with our mouth.
With words.
Oh, no.
I mean, with words.
Where are you bullying?
With words.
Oh, okay.
That's what she means.
We'll just...
We'll say very mean words to them.
Yeah.
And they'll go away.
Sticks and stones.
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't it probably like the opposite?
Like, it'll sense when you talk or something and then it'll find you.
Oh, probably.
Just say, won't they find us?
Apparently, this game is made by one person.
Oh.
We can attribute everything to them.
Yeah, that's true.
She made it!
I'm in!
Oh my god!
Alright, I'll start the...
I'll start the lobby.
Okay, wait.
Should we mute everybody?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I forgot.
She didn't choose her color.
Alright, she's white now.
Okay.
I'm white!
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Wait, we turn everybody to zero, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We turn everyone to zero in Discord.
Okay, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Hello?
Alright, I'm gonna turn...
I'm gonna fix the audio.
Hello?
Oh, gosh.
Hello!
It's so...
low.
I'm gonna turn my mic up.
Pretty quiet.
This is...
Okay, my mic up is up.
Is it up for you guys?
Uh, a little bit.
It's a little better.
Could be better.
Alright.
It's at 250.
250?
Okay, I'll put mine at 250.
Oh, that's the max.
Yeah.
Me too.
Hello?
No, louder.
250.
Put it at 250.
I said 250.
I put it at 250.
250!
It was...
It did improve for the others, but...
Bruce is still a little quiet.
Wait, Nimmi, can you try talking?
Hello!
Komakuwa!
I'm gonna turn...
Everybody's so quiet.
Maybe...
Maybe we turn the...
game...
Like, volume.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
I'm doing that right now.
I'm turning the volume to max too.
Wait.
There's only...
The monsters are gonna be so...
loud.
I'm turning the game.
Yeah.
Everything's gonna be really loud.
I turn the...
Oh wait, I'm gonna turn the game- other game stuff lower.
How do you do that though?
I don't think- Yeah, is there other game stuff?
There's only- Oh, here we go, that should've fixed it.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Gooby, you did it!
How did you fix it?
Oh, oh.
You fixed it!
Oh my god!
It's good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you loud now?
It's too loud?
No, you're like- What?
Should I turn it down?
No, it's good.
It's good.
I turned it down a little.
It's- it's like peeking, so like, it's like- I hear like- It doesn't peek for us, but your setup is peeking and like, we can only hear like- Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh- Can I get your order?
Master volume.
You turn down the master volume, and that's the game.
The game is master.
It's not- also- The game doesn't affect the voices.
Oh, no, it does.
The master volume also affects voices, yeah.
Oh, it does.
Never mind, it does.
I just turn- Yeah, I turn it back up.
Well, w- w- Doobie, how did you fix it on your end?
Fix that?
What did- what did you do?
What?
Oh, I just turned that motion volume.
Does it still sound bad?
I'm so loud!
Aw.
Well, luckily- Luckily, we're all streaming our POVs, so- Yeah, like- Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Someone will combine it, I guess.
Someone will sync up all our audio together.
Quite the work they've done ahead of them.
Sorry, everyone.
The ultimate compilation.
I don't- like, I don't understand.
Why is there no individual toggles?
I don't know!
It's just- Okay.
It really feels like we're in space, guys.
I don't think we're in space, though.
Wait, we can't jump!
This is a parking lot.
It feels just like- Why are we in the parking lot?
I can't crouch- Oh, wait.
Oh, I can't crouch.
Okay, it's still- Oh, yes.
He is crouch.
Wait, how do we get- Oh, my God!
Whoa!
Yay!
How do you dance?
Yeah, how do you dance?
It's called G.
G?
Oh, I see.
What's this?
Whoa!
Oh, yeah!
Wait!
It's Doobie!
It's actual Doobie!
Wait, what's happening to me?
Oh, hello!
Why did I go over there?
We just do- Wow, guys.
I didn't know space was just a parking lot.
I- Yeah.
Oh, you have a creepy van, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Ew.
What are we trying to do?
Oh, you can get in!
You saw the image.
You saw- What are we implying here?
Alright, where do we go?
So we have equipment.
I don't know.
We're supposed to turn on electricity on the first floor.
Oh, right here.
Yeah, we have an objective.
Oh my god, it's Phasmo.
Don't say that.
Wait.
Wait, I don't have a flashlight.
Oh!
Wait, we sound better in here!
Okay.
Oh, it's echo-y in here.
Oh!
I like it.
The words that can be interacted with or highlighted with a faint light.
That's good to know.
Oh, there's a special book.
Wait, what?
What's this?
I can't read it.
Oh!
The words that can be interacted with or highlighted with a faint light.
Someone else read this.
Special book number one.
Oh my god, Doobie scared me so bad.
What does it say?
Special book.
Wait, how do you read?
What does it say, Mint?
Hello?
Mint?
Yeah?
Mint, are you okay?
Mint?
Wait, can you not hear me?
Stop talking!
Mint, Doobie, you're not talking!
I'm talking!
Wait, does it limit us when we enter the building and we're like in our own little like- Hello!
In our dimension.
The pocket dimension where we can only hear- Oh no, the yellow and green.
We can't split.
The yellow and green.
Wait, I can't hear Doobie though.
It's like, you know, it's like wife swap.
Wait, hold on.
I think there's a text, no?
Text?
Okay.
It's okay, we can do this.
Yeah.
I'm gonna leave and come back in.
Hello?
Hurry outside!
Wife swap.
Hello?
I'm scary looking.
Oh, the cat!
Whoa!
Oh, he's alive!
Okay, we got five with power.
Oh, he's powering!
Is this a collab?
We can figure out where.
Oh, okay, so doobie, I can hear you all of a sudden.
I should unmute you.
Wait.
I can hear!
I can hear you!
I can hear you, Doobie!
Just here people hear you, dude!
Wait, can he hear you?
Yeah, I can hear you.
I got jump... jump scared my game into hearing again.
Wait, apparently it was... we just clicked V on accident.
Oh!
You went in your own pocket and said...
You muted yourself!
Yeah.
You just muted by accident.
I pressed V!
Why?
Because we were probably trying to find a cool emo or something.
Yeah, I was probably trying to press G and then...
Whoa!
Okay, anyway, there was an alien outside that window.
But we heard it.
I don't believe you.
Yeah, I don't know.
It was really loud, I'm scared.
I got a TV!
Oh, nice!
What's on the TV?
It says, uh, no signal.
You got gimch.
Okay, we got electricity.
Wait, this looks like electricity.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, turn that on.
Nice, we did the first task.
Wait, the cat is...
Oh, the cat!
Oh, no, the cat's still sleeping.
I thought he was awake.
I don't think there's a space.
Wait, what's this?
What the...?
What's the transmitter?
Wait.
Why is there a moon in the...
Like...
We have to find the moon, right?
Oh, yeah, we have to find the moon, yeah.
Wait, maybe we're gonna build a rocket.
It says to explore the basement.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Good.
Well, we're on the first floor, so we gotta go downstairs.
It's locked.
It's on the other side.
Oh, down here?
Is the sensitivity weird for anybody else?
It's a dead end.
Oh, um, just do the controls.
It's on controls.
Is it?
Yeah, I turned mine down.
Yeah, I turned mine down, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna turn mine down.
Ah, it's sensitive.
It's already at one.
My chat's like...
Um, actually, Earth is also in space.
Maybe like that.
Oh, that's better.
True.
What's this?
Brain chat.
I'll go live.
We're just LARPing.
Clothes on the other side.
Oh, there's more over here.
Oh.
We kind of are.
Like, we put on our spacesuits already.
We're not even...
Yeah, we're like these kids that are like...
Failed the save game.
Oh, we're here?
We're here?
Oh, yes.
The theme has been saved.
Oh, okay.
Map data.
Oh, this has to be the basement.
It doesn't have to be.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, we can change your color.
Doobie, you don't have to be white anymore.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'll be blue.
Blue.
Yeah.
What's happening?
It's a different blue than mince blue, right?
I can't tell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's cute.
What's this?
What is all this?
Oh, we have...
Oh, get previously researched items.
Oh, wait.
Is this the book that we...
Wait.
Oh?
Current objective is displayed in the corner.
Yeah, we know.
Okay.
What's on the other side?
How do we get out of here?
Why is space so lame?
The last time I was alone, something happened.
I like how...
Like, it's like...
We're in like a little suburban area.
Yeah.
We're gonna swear to school or something, right?
Isn't there something scary out there, though?
Do you see that?
What?
See what?
Find that building over there?
What?
I don't see anything.
Something.
Are you sure any...
Do you take your meds, Mimi?
She's right there, I swear.
I see it.
It's right by the building.
What?
Uh...
That's just a regular kid.
That's just...
Why?
There's a kid?
That's...
No, yeah.
You guys not see that kid over there?
That's not a kid...
Yeah!
There's a regular...
There's a kid out there.
Do you want to see it?
Is that in the corner?
Yeah, he's a kid.
It's like, 12 feet tall.
What?
He took his vitamins.
He took...
He ate his greens.
And grew to 12 feet tall.
That's like Popeye.
When your nurse starts seeing things, I start worrying.
This is the...
No, we didn't go forward.
This feels like a safe room, no?
What's... what's over there, though?
Oh, it's a safe terminal.
Okay, but where is, like, the fucking basement?
Was it where we were before?
Weren't there stairs?
Maybe we're supposed to find...
Oh!
Oh, the one area we didn't go.
Maybe there... oh, there's a lot of stuff in here.
A monitor.
Oh, a shelf for special books!
Oh, the special book!
I'll go get it.
Alright.
He needs a monitor, right?
Monitor?
Oh, yeah.
And then our special book, which was...
I think it's in here.
Oh, there it is.
My special book.
I think it's in here.
It has a special book in everything.
I got the special book.
I don't think there's stamina in this desert.
Oh, so you can hold three items, it seems.
Special book?
Apply item.
Okay, nice.
Wait.
If you're confused and don't know what to do, check with the...
Oh, I thought that said check with the cat.
It's
our little safe room.
Oh!
I brought the TV!
Yay!
Oh, guys, we found the basement!
Does it work?
Oh, yay!
Yeah, I found the basement.
There were stairs that we forgot.
I think you put the...
Wait, it says installation monitor.
Here?
Wait, monitor.
We put the monitor here?
Monitor.
The TV's a monitor.
It's not.
You're open.
Guys, I don't think it's the TV...
I don't think it's the TV.
I think it's the TV too old.
It's not like a TV monitor.
Yeah.
It's not.
It's like a CRT.
I'm just gonna take a load off right here.
Don't ask me a monitor anymore.
Alright, we found the...
Men, get the fuck up.
Okay.
We have...
We gotta find the moon!
We gotta, yeah, we gotta explore the basement.
We gotta find the moon, guys.
Over here.
It's down here.
Okay.
A moon!
Is there any explanation for the giant cat?
It's a moon cat.
I like him though.
It makes me feel comfortable.
He's purring.
Maybe he's like a guard dog, but a cat.
Maybe space is okay.
Yeah.
Space has giant cats.
Oh, this is a very suspicious entrance.
What if we go upstairs?
What's up here?
Um, it says explore the basement.
They're gonna punish you.
No.
They wouldn't.
Clothes on the other side.
I think we have to do the basement before we can unlock the other floors.
Probably.
Yeah, it seems like it.
Can we leave there?
Is that open?
Can we go out the window?
Oh, we can't jump.
To a flip.
All right, let's go downstairs.
All right.
Do you need a break?
You're a very great dancer.
I've seen you break dance.
You can take this.
Oh my god, you're so great to me.
Sometimes the, sometimes the, you're just, the sounds sound a little weird.
It cuts off so bad.
You don't care about me.
You don't care.
I do.
Of course I care.
My knight is shining over.
Elevator.
When dying, if there are other surviving players.
Bye bye.
Bye.
We have to go in.
All players must be in.
Oh, wow.
It's really upset.
I don't like elevators.
I know.
I'm scared.
I get dizzy if you want an elevator.
Basement 2.
There's a basement too?
That's just another basement.
Wait, do you guys have flashlights?
It's...
Yeah.
Oh.
How do you turn it on?
F.
F?
Look at that guy.
It was the kid from outside.
This is the 12 feet guy.
The 12 feet guy.
Oh my gosh, she did see a guy.
Oh gosh, we're like colliding so bad.
Oh, we need a lever.
We need to find a lever.
A lever.
Alright.
I can't see anything.
Someone with a flashlight, go first.
I have a flashlight.
You don't have a flashlight?
No.
I swear you're holding one.
It's a transmitter.
Whatever that is.
Yeah.
Oh, I think because you're holding a transmitter.
I think someone's dead.
Oh!
Wait, someone's dead?
Who's dead?
Oh my god, that was you!
Wait, yeah.
It's Doopie's old body.
That was me.
That's my old body.
It's Doopie 1.
You mean I was cloned?
Every time you change color, you're just cloning yourself.
There's a movie like that, but I don't want to say what it is because it's a spoiler for the whole movie.
What is that?
Why is it running towards me?
This is the end.
Oh, okay.
This is for you, Doopie 1.
Doopie Alpha.
It's like that, the Mickey, what was it, the one with Robert Pattinson?
Oh, I like that movie, Mickey 17.
Yeah, Mickey 17.
That was, that was Doopie, Doopie 16.
Wait, wait, where did Doopie 17 go?
Um...
Wait, where did Doopie 17 go?
Doopie?
Wait, oh, oh, there's a monster down here!
Wait, there's a monster!
Oh, my godめて, doopie!
Take me, get Doopie!
Take me, get the Doopie!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!!
Oh, definitely!
Oh, this is...
This is Eric!
Doopie!
Doopie?
Oh!
Don't think we can go back up, I think I...
I guess we're about to meet Doopie 18.
Doobie 17 is gone.
I think it opened up this thing right here.
But I'm scared to go.
Oh, apparently Doobie crashed.
No!
Okay, the timing of that was crazy.
Wait, should we restart?
Do we have to restart?
Yeah, we're pretty early.
Yeah, we're pretty early on because we didn't know what to do.
I kind of want to see what happens.
Alright, you guys want to die to the monster together?
Yeah.
Alright, we'll go.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
Sorry, guys.
Prepare your ears.
Wait, where was he?
Over here.
Oh, there he is!
Oh, he's still here.
Alright, who wants to die first?
I'll go!
Alright, we'll watch.
She's gonna get the screenshot!
Oh!
There it is!
Was that you taking a screenshot?
I don't know!
That was crazy!
I'll make a new lobby.
We all ended up back here.
Yeah, we gotta make a new lobby.
Okay, I'm in new lobby.
Oh, wowie, guys.
Um...
Ducky burn.
It
is actually louder!
Oh, it's awfully...
Alright, let me...
Okay, we made a new lobby.
Holy shit!
I did not expect that test.
I...
It's so loud!
Oh, wait, I got pee.
No.
Alright, I...
I...
Um...
I messaged Julie that we made a new lobby.
Yeah.
So, we'll just wait.
Yeah, I'm trying to send an invite.
Because I wasn't able to send an invite.
Alright, I'm gonna get water real quick.
I'll be back.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I'm back.
No, don't be sorry!
No problem.
We...
We thought you died horribly.
We did!
We thought you got...
But as soon as we turned the corner...
To go look for you, we found the monster.
I did.
That's what happened.
That's why.
It disconnected me.
I'm back.
I thought...
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're back.
You...
You crashed at, like, the perfect time.
We're like...
Oh, man.
Hope we got to clone Doobie 17.
And then he disappeared.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we know, we know.
Uh...
Yeah, yeah, okay.
We know what the alien does.
We know.
What?
What do you mean?
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Actually, no.
We can watch Doobie also encounter him.
What?
Yeah, Doobie.
We all...
It's like an initiation.
We all did it.
We all...
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Alright.
He's friendly, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Very friendly.
We all got a hug from him, right, guys?
Uh...
This isn't related to the picture you guys showed me earlier.
Um...
Oh!
There he is!
Oh, okay.
There he is.
Oh!
He really just does that, doesn't he?
Yeah.
Alright.
Doobie 18.
Woohoo!
Time to get to work.
Is this right?
Wasn't he around here?
I'm scared.
Yeah, I think he's around the corner.
I think he's on the left side.
We'll watch.
He's right here.
Okay, ready?
I see him.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna die him?
No, no.
No.
How do we get him not to see us, though?
I think we can go left.
Yeah, I think we have to go around him.
Yeah.
Wait, this is just the beginning.
This is the area.
Is it?
Yeah, we looped.
Like a...
Like a little shortcut area.
I think because we're supposed to find the lever handle.
What's this?
Don't let it see you.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, okay.
Easy?
That should be easy.
We could use one of us as bae.
Okay, Doki.
Good idea.
You should go.
As the idea person here...
If I die, who else will have all these good ideas?
He's gone, I think.
I don't see him.
Oh, okay.
Mm-hmm.
He hears your footsteps?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Okay.
Closed.
Oh.
You know, like...
Okay, we looked like that character in...
Oh, I think he's coming.
Wait.
Oh.
I'm stuck!
Yay!
Oh, my God.
They...
The monster cry threw me on top of my body, so I couldn't move.
I got...
It was...
He's...
He's the Costco guy.
He's gonna get four big boobs.
Big boobs.
Uh...
Boo!
How do we do this?
We just...
We gotta go right...
Don't let him see you.
Yeah, don't let him see you.
Yeah, he got all of us.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I was just standing there.
I thought maybe he wouldn't get me if I just stood still.
Can he hear our microphone?
Does that play in there?
It says...
Oh, I don't know.
No, it says, don't let it see you, though.
No, it also said he hears your footsteps, though.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, so we just have to crouch.
Yeah, I think so.
Okay, be very, very quiet.
I'm hunting wabbits.
Wabbits, yeah.
I don't wanna see where this line goes.
Be very, very quiet.
Be very quiet.
Okay, I think, like, he...
He does go back and go forward, so, like, we just gotta wait for him to do that, right?
Yeah, we know that it's a dead end now, but we can open up this.
Yeah.
Yeah, which we...
Why don't you guys open the door?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, you scared me!
Alright.
We just gotta wait for him to come back.
And then he'll, like, go forward.
Oh, right, yeah, cause we have to make the first right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then he did come back.
But I think he'll see us here, right?
He did before.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, no.
There was a...
No, no, no.
Cause, like, Nimi ran up to him, remember?
Oh, that's...
I did run up to him.
That's right, that's right.
Yeah, so I...
Maybe he's, like...
You know, like, there's some animals that can't see, like, more than, like, five feet?
You can hear him coming, too.
Like, things just get...
It's like how, like, crocodiles can't see in front of them.
Oh, there you go.
See?
Let's shimmy over.
Why are we laughing?
Because I don't think we should be in the dead end.
Oh, there was a thing here.
Oh.
Can we turn our flashlights off?
Okay.
Uh, now what?
Guys, I think it's a bad idea.
I think we should...
Should we go?
Why?
You didn't have to follow me!
You were the leader!
Okay.
Wait, maybe we're fine.
Maybe we can go.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I don't hear him.
Let's go.
Maybe he jumped out the window.
Yeah, maybe he could.
Yeah, yeah.
You know what?
I believe that.
Maybe he jumped off the building.
Oh!
I don't think he jumped off the building.
I think only doki's alive will never make it.
I think only doki's alive will never...
will never...
get anywhere.
What?
Oh!
Ah!
I'm okay.
I can like hear you barely.
You're so quiet.
Yeah.
Is it just me?
I'm fine.
You're so quiet.
Hello?
Oh.
Wait, write a message.
I'll be a hero.
Can you hear me?
I don't think they can.
I can't hear...
Oh, they are the...
I think maybe the bodies are proximity, maybe.
Oh my god, where am I?
I can see them like they're...
Oh, kinda.
Oh!
Hello!
She's doing it.
There's the lever!
Right?
Why?
Is that...
Doki!
Is that not the lever?
You're not stuck.
You're nowhere else to go.
You gotta find the lever, Doki!
It's so quiet.
No!
I miss it.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Nobody sees me here, right?
No!
How did she live?
Is that not the lever right there?
Oh, see, see, see.
Oh, it's something.
I think that's the lever!
I'm the main character.
I think so.
Gaming?
They sound like little ants to me.
Oh.
Oh no, don't die here.
Don't die here.
Come on.
What is that?
Is that a monitor?
She can take it back.
Maybe.
I don't...
Does she know how to get back?
Oh!
She made it.
I did it.
Oh my god, I did it.
I saved the run!
Yay!
Okay, guys, I did it.
Guys, I'm a hero.
You're welcome.
We're
back!
Thank you!
You did it, Doki.
You did it!
It's like, surprise!
I'm gonna be honest, I didn't have any faith in you.
That's right!
That was amazing!
Bro, when he was like in... I was just up here in the corner, and he just walked past me.
Yeah!
Wow!
They were gaming.
Oh, we're outside!
Oh my god.
We're outside now, yeah!
We're down the street.
Wait, we can go see the little kid.
Yay!
I think they're gone.
I think they're inside.
You better hide.
Wait, what does that mean?
But we're outside!
I'm gonna hide.
I'm gonna hide back in...
Let me turn around!
Did anyone survive?
What am I supposed to do?
Get into the library.
Over here?
Is this the library?
It looks...
Uh...
I think it is.
Wait.
Yeah!
What was that?
What happened?
I don't know.
I was...
I was unlocked.
Because Doofy was like not moving.
I was changing his setting.
I was trying to fix his setting.
When died or others...
The players become...
When they're...
This is like basically how to revive people.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
What was that thing though?
That was crazy.
I don't know.
That was higher.
It was crazy.
Yeah, it was a god headspotter.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, you carry three items.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
We just have to follow the lives.
Storage of electrical...
Okay, we get...
Oh, wait.
We have electrical boxes?
Oh, where'd you get those?
Electrical boxes and apply them to empty slots of electrical circuits.
I got a computer.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Feel it.
Electrical boxes.
I use gaming computers.
That's good.
Gaming PC?
What's this?
Complete the electrical circuit and...
Provide power to the door to unlock it.
Oh.
Do it for me.
Or take a seat.
We gotta provide power to the door.
That's what it's saying.
Alright.
But I have...
I have one of the electrical...
Oh, there you go.
I found one.
Yeah, I found an empty slot.
Oh!
I found it!
It's like there are like little squares on the thing.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you gotta like apply it.
Okay, okay.
Is there another one here?
I see, I see.
Oh.
They're all gone.
Oh, one here.
One on me, one on me.
Oh.
There.
Okay.
Nice.
I have one more.
One here, one here.
Yeah.
Nice.
There has to be another one.
Where did you find the first couple?
Oh.
We put that in here.
Nothing in there.
Oh, there's one here.
But we don't have any more like...
Unlock the door first.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Like a...
Maybe we have to unlock this door first.
Which one?
Is there one we can take from...
This...
This one on the other side.
Can you change them out?
Green.
Cause I think we have to unlock the...
The door.
The...
Green.
Yeah, I'm gonna take this one.
Maybe...
Maybe this one over here first.
Yeah.
The one by the entrance.
Wait, so if I take this...
One...
I have one more.
I took it from the other side.
If we put here...
Right on.
Looks like a weed.
Oh, here.
Okay.
And then you put one...
Here.
Oh, it does look like a weed.
No, no.
I think we gotta do this one first.
Hold on.
Oh, okay.
I think we do...
Here.
Right?
No, no.
Apply.
Empty slide.
And then...
It goes...
To the right side first.
Oh, wait.
This doesn't go anywhere.
Yeah, I don't know where...
It all meets up.
I thought it was in this door.
I think it's all connected.
I think we have to do...
This side.
This wall first.
The way to the left side.
Computer's gonna get wet.
Your precious computer.
Your computer.
The gaming PC.
Okay.
I'm gonna do the left side.
Is that...
Up there?
No.
There's an item in my pocket.
Uh...
I have one extra for this side.
But there's anything else.
Where does it go?
Wait, maybe there's something...
Oh.
Oh look, I found a sword.
There's two electrical boxes in this...
Oh!
Nice!
Wait, can we crawl through here?
Oh.
I got one.
Can you just yoink it?
Yeah.
Hey!
That's one!
Wait, why is it not...
turning green though?
I got my PC.
Oh.
Maybe cause...
Oh!
I'm so dumb.
It's all connected.
Yeah, I think so.
Over here, over here, over here.
Wait, where?
Right there?
Oh, I see it, I see it.
And now it should all be connected.
We just missed that one.
Yeah, okay, okay.
That was...
That one was hidden.
Yeah, we solved the puzzle!
Yay!
Our brain screwed three times that day.
There
was a monster running around over here.
Wait, install the monitor.
That's what this monitor's for!
Doobie, your time!
Yeah!
Your time, it's your time to shine!
Where do...
Oh, right here?
No, this is input device one.
Wait, do we need the transmitter?
Uh-oh.
Is that what they're telling us?
It's just a book and song.
No, no, I have one of the devices.
I want to play with this puzzle.
You guys can't...
I'm done with this toy.
I want to play with this new toy.
I believe in you.
Wait, yeah, actually...
Please do that, Wardens.
Yeah, we'll watch...
This is the...
We'll watch Doobie solve this puzzle.
Yeah.
Wait.
This is too...
No pressure.
No, no, no.
All three of us are watching right now.
You got this.
Maybe I messed it up.
No, you didn't.
No, yo.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna start backseating.
I think it's a pie.
Streamer, why didn't you move that tile shape down?
You have to slide the tile.
Oh my god.
You just had it.
Slide it the way that I would slide it, I think.
Too realistic.
Move that one.
Streamer, you should have moved the other one.
You just had it.
You had the...
Oh my gosh, Streamer.
Why did you do that?
Move.
I solved it in two seconds.
My bad.
Um...
My child was able to solve this.
Yeah!
A special book!
I knew she could do it.
Wait, is that a Ouija board?
A Luigi board?
I think we need a cable.
I'm pretty sure we have to move forward, right?
There's a...
There's a monster running about.
So, uh...
If you go outside, be careful.
Yeah.
I mean, we could come back here.
What's the book do?
I think we put it...
Oh, it's a...
There was like that one room.
Remember that office we unlocked?
Yeah, yeah.
They said we could like...
Keep it.
Oh.
Maybe there's gonna be a safe room or something.
Yeah.
Put it there.
I'll... I'll read it.
It's my...
Fan fiction.
I'll bring the...
I'll bring the special board.
We gotta go.
To install this, we have to defeat the monster.
No...
I'm scared.
Defeat?
There's something outside.
I saw it run in the hallway upstairs.
Oh, there's a safe spot here.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, this is...
Yeah, this is...
Wait.
This is...
Isn't this the elevator we went down to the basement before?
Oh, so we have to go back.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so if we go this way...
Oh, we go back.
Yeah.
Oh, then we like plug in these for the...
The...
Our room.
Yeah, I think so.
Our sweet gaming room.
Wait.
Did you hear that?
You hear that?
Hahahaha.
Fako!
Wait.
This is where I saw the monster running around.
It's a snake!
We ate it!
Awww.
It's, a...
It's a...
It's an ink monster!
Yeah, looks...
Like stems from...
Ah, he's friendly!
Hey, look guys.
What's that?
Is that a robot waifu?
Wait, what?
A waifu?
Yeah, you see her?
Oh, she is kind of leaning into the wall.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
That's scary.
You guys shouldn't get too close to that.
She's like that... like the girl version of that Resident Evil guy.
Hey, you looking for something too?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, I'm looking for a partner.
A wife.
She's like the...
The guy in Resident Evil 2?
Oh, what are you buying?
No, no, no, no, no.
Is it Resident Evil 2?
The guy that chases you in a trench coat with like a girl version.
Wait, what did we give her?
The worm.
Keyboard, please.
The moon?
How can the moon even be there?
Oh, I have the keyboard.
The worm is being really noisy behind me.
I don't like it.
She sounds really wet.
Oh, this is Mrs. X.
But she has anime eyes.
Look at this.
Oh, look at her eyes.
Look at her eyes.
No objective.
Find out the password.
Use chat with the manager.
Bro thinks he's part of the team.
Yeah.
Inky, get out of here.
That's chat.
Get out of here.
This is chat.
Hey, guys.
I'm here to help with that puzzle from earlier.
How do we find the password?
Use chat with a ma...
What the fuck is this?
At chat.
What's the password?
He's in here.
He's making the ground nasty.
You're disgusting.
Shower.
Shower now.
You're not an indoor...
I'm sorry.
That
was a little fun of him.
I learned my lesson.
What you did?
You got angry.
You said that to him.
Wait.
What?
Oh,
wait.
No.
We can revive her at the save point right here.
Oh, yeah.
Where are you?
She went the wrong way.
Oh, there we go.
Hi, guys.
Hi.
Hold on, I gotta get the monitor.
I dropped it.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Wait, no, we went the other way before.
Is it the elevator?
No, we went this way before.
I think we just got unlucky.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we did.
We literally went over and then just slammed us.
Yeah.
I took one for the team.
Where did it come from?
I thought I heard it.
Don't reach out angry.
The worm is not friendly.
Whoever said that.
Just ignore him.
Yeah, ignore him.
You were so mean to him.
You think he heard me insulting him?
Talk to the anime girl again.
Guys, you summoned.
He's unemployed.
I'm sorry.
I don't mean to tell you to shower.
I got a special book.
Don't look at him.
Don't even look at him.
Yeah, don't even look at him.
Enter the password.
What's a four letter?
He can open doors.
The password is eight zero zero eight.
Boob.
There's no letters.
I mean, there's no numbers.
We can do regular.
Wait, is it?
B-O-O, yeah.
Yeah, we can just do actual boob.
Yeah, just actually write boob.
I don't think that's it.
Just chat with the manager.
Yeah.
You think it's mood?
Somebody has to go woo the manager.
Who's the manager?
Yeah.
I think it's that lady.
I want to speak to your manager.
Oh, I got it.
What was the password?
It was moon.
Oh, the transmitter.
Huge brain.
Wait.
What is?
Oh no, the transmitter.
Where is it?
It's right here.
No, everybody.
Look!
Run!
Get out!
What are we doing?
He appeared!
He pooped himself.
Wait.
Is that?
Oh, nope, nope.
That's a bad guy.
You guys all ran, so, I'm just following you.
I thought that was Doobie coming out.
It's Hang on down!
I feel like.
Remember when we were holding a transmitter earlier?
Yeah.
Where did we leave it?
We should go save somewhere.
I think so too, yeah.
Yeah, okay, but where did we leave the transmitter?
No, it can't be that far.
No.
I think it was in the basement, no?
Yeah.
Yeah, no, it had to be.
We left items.
Oh, I think it was when... I think it was at the very beginning of the basement.
The beginning of... Okay, well, that was easy.
Yeah, we know how to get that.
Yeah, yeah, with the man, with the slam dunker.
Well, he's upstairs now, so... Oh, okay.
Well, we just have to... Okay, we... One of us just has to live.
Okay.
All right, I'll stay here.
It's all on you, doobs.
No, wait, I don't want to stay.
It'll be boring.
We'll be alone.
Okay, I'm going to crouch walk.
Yeah, I will be fine.
Okay, but how... Yeah, I was going to say, how would Doobie know when we're all dead?
When we never come back.
We just never come back.
We just... It's just... She waits an hour alone in the room and was like, God, I think she might be dead.
Yeah.
The Doobie waiting room.
Where was... Oh, there was a save right at the bottom here, so we could just... Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I remember.
I remember that, too.
Me, too.
The Lobster's probably camping at the save point.
He probably is.
I can't believe that it's not, like, a safe point.
Like, it's a save point, but it's not a safe point.
It's not safe.
It's not a safe room.
Yeah.
There is no safe room.
Okay, let's see.
Yeah, the room feels pretty safe.
We all died in there from the ink blob.
Okay, we go downstairs, right?
Someone didn't piss him off.
What?
I don't... He got pissed off again.
Doobie?
Oh, wait.
Did Doobie crash again?
Doobie.
Oh, I hear her.
I hear her.
Oh, no, not here.
Doobie.
Doobie, Marko.
Doob, doob, doobie.
Doobie?
Oh, it's like, bad.
Whoa, what's going on in there?
Doobie.
See all the lights?
Um, there's an evil creature out there.
Do you see that?
I don't see an evil creature.
The one that's 12 feet tall?
Yes!
Come, look.
Stand right where I'm standing.
Oh, it's a... No, it's the cat.
Is that a cat?
Yeah.
It has red eyes, so it must be evil.
Oh, cat, there's evil.
He's scanning.
No.
Guys, guys, don't look behind me.
Oh, no.
Wait, where's Doobie?
Do you think he got her?
No, because her body would be coming after us.
Hi.
Where are you?
I see her, I hear her.
She's like, here.
Hello.
All right, we go this way.
Got an easter egg.
Easter egg found.
Basement number two.
Hey, now where's Min?
I'm here.
Oh, you guys are waiting for me.
Sorry.
It's okay.
It was in basement number two.
Yeah.
All right.
Don't let him on the uncle.
Wait.
Yeah, don't let him...
Wait, we're going to basement two?
No boys allowed.
Yeah, it was a transmitter.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was like right here.
It's where you all died and I live.
Oh, yeah, here it is.
Okay, okay.
And became a hero.
Oh, he's there, he's there, he's there.
Okay, one of us, one of us has to live.
One of us, only really one of us has to go.
Only one of us transmitted.
I'm trying to see if I left it over here.
I'm not avoiding this situation.
I'm just checking.
I think it is in that hallway.
I think so too.
I think it's where we first initially died.
Yeah.
No, like, cause I never came back.
So it's by the dead end area.
Yeah.
I'll go.
It's the right one?
Yeah, no, it's the right side.
Yeah.
Yeah, the first dead end on the right.
Oh, over there?
I see it.
Oh, you do?
Got it.
Alright.
Yeah, now we go back.
Okay.
Let's go, let's go, before he sees us.
Wait, which way is up?
Um...
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
Right here, right here.
Okay, that's...
I like how all of us were hacked.
That's all we needed?
There wasn't something else?
Yeah, that was it, I think.
It was just the transmitter.
Yeah.
Yippee!
What's there a way we can summon items that we have had before?
I don't think so.
I don't know.
This whole chat's not here anymore.
Okay, make sure we all save.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
This way.
Oh, this way.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
You okay?
Screams.
Alright.
Doesn't elaborate.
What about the sexy lady?
Should we invite her?
Are we gonna transmit it to her?
Yes.
Yeah.
She's the same language.
Oh!
And say, oh.
Talk to the strange lady.
Oh.
Transmitting data?
That's it.
Oh!
Okay.
She's, she's...
I got her!
I, I scored!
Step aside!
I scored the woman!
Oh my god!
She's...
She's mine!
She's following me!
Wow, miss!
You risked her!
I risked her!
I said...
I said, dot, dot, dot, and she followed.
She likes the silent type, huh?
Yeah!
Dot, dot, dot.
Ooh!
She said you don't know where to go next.
Oh, she's talking.
She's talking.
Let's go there.
Explore the secret passage.
Secret passage?
Oh!
She's leading us!
Whoa!
Wait, will you take this?
Transmitter?
She has to duck!
I think we used it!
Yeah!
I think you could keep it in here, probably.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Look at her go!
The tall, big, strong woman!
It's a...
It's a runway now!
Damn!
Oh!
It's America's next taumata!
No!
What's up here?
Wait, I'm stuck in!
Wait, there's a monster in here.
Hold on.
There is?
There's a guy right there.
Oh, there's him!
There's the big guy!
Yeah.
Ew!
He'll see you!
Be careful!
Wait, should we save right here?
There's a save thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's save.
Come back, come back.
Unless we don't see the big, strong lady again.
Okay, we're good.
Okay, good, good.
Okay.
It was all a dream.
Oh, he's walking.
Yeah, he's coming this way.
Oh, no!
Yeah, he just left.
Alright.
I see her outside.
Oh, she's outside?
She's waiting for us in the rain.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, I wanna see.
That's so cute.
Oh, sorry.
See, look out the window over there.
I don't know if you see your girlfriend.
Oh, I see her.
Yeah, she's over there.
Wait, I hear some...
What are you looking at?
Is that her?
She heard that?
Footsteps?
Oh.
Her foot...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
He's walking around.
Oh.
Oh, there she is.
I see her.
Okay, good.
Yeah.
As long as he doesn't see us.
Our anime girlfriend.
He's coming, he's coming.
Oh.
Guys, I don't think Doobie lives.
We can go save.
Ah!
Uh...
Did Doki live?
Hello?
You got five?
Wait!
I think I have to press it again.
Yeah, where's Doki?
Hi, Doki!
I started hearing her scream from far away.
Um...
Oh, it's got a cooldown.
Yeah.
Oh, I see.
Wait, that's weird that it let us...
Yeah.
Again?
Oh!
Yay!
I literally died the moment Nimi responded, you guys.
Yeah!
He's like right there, hold on.
Oh, yeah.
He's tough.
He's a big strong man.
Yeah.
He's out here getting ready for basketball.
Oh.
He scares me.
Alright.
Shining in his eyes.
Yeah.
He looks like an actual imposter.
He reminds me of the Slenderman.
Yeah.
Explore the hole in the wall to the outside.
He looks like Slenderman.
So we gotta go outside.
Alright.
Somehow.
Oh, gosh.
Is he just walking back and forth?
I think he sees one of us.
And it was you.
You cannot powerslide in this.
Kinda sucks.
It's my last words.
It's my last
words.
Aww.
Mimi's so brave.
Let's go, Nimi.
Okay, we're safe.
No!
Chad got her!
Oh, no way.
Yeah.
Yeah, look at...
Is she gonna come over here and get me?
No?
Yeah, come over.
We gotta bring her back.
He came through the wall.
Oh, my God.
He was trying to get me.
Wait, do you guys hear that?
You hear footsteps, right?
I hear footsteps.
Yeah.
Do you guys hear that?
I heard it last time, too.
Hello.
Hello, welcome back.
Did you guys got grabbed by chat?
No, no.
It was the big guy.
What was that?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, he's...
He's coming through the wall.
He's got tentacles.
Wait, maybe I'll stay here and distract him.
You guys go forward.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, actually, he went back, I think.
I think he went back, yeah.
Okay, I think...
Okay, I got a plan.
One of us has to be bait.
And then the other...
Oh, wait.
I think if you get into the other room, you can open the door there.
Yeah.
Only one of us has to live.
I mean, if we all die, we just go...
We spawn right back at that safe spot, so...
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there.
Only one of us has...
I'll distract him.
Don't worry, guys.
No, I...
Okay, you be the hero.
Go, Doobie, go!
Or...
Oh.
Okay, I don't think she...
I'm somewhere.
There's a map?
Hello?
Oh, hey, guys.
We all live.
Yeah, but...
Where do we go?
It says we're supposed to go outside, but...
There's supposed...
There's supposedly a map?
Oh, he's over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can't...
What is this?
Wait, he's coming though.
Go, Doobie!
Save yourself!
Come on here.
There's nothing.
There's nothing in front of us.
Okay.
Uh, it's just...
I was the distraction.
Should?
Oh, gosh.
Uh-oh.
Ow!
Ow, gosh!
Oh, she made it.
Wow.
Look at the cone is going!
Oh, no.
I don't know what the body...
Ew!
What?
I don't know what the...
What the hell is that?
Oh, my god!
From before?
Oh, it's just stopping her.
What is the goal here?
Oh, she made it back in.
I think Nimi will...
Oh, what's that right there?
Oh, some books.
Oh.
Can you see me?
I think she's...
Oh, no!
You're not still alive!
She's got a...
Oh, he's here!
Oh, god!
The inky man!
Oh, I can't hear them again.
There's too many!
Wait, is there a safe room?
Is that where?
I'm gonna eat my sandwich.
That's the third floor, but where's the safe?
The basement?
That's so unfair!
There.
One lucky!
You left Nimi!
Where did you live?
You were the chosen one.
But we know where the door is now.
You were the chosen one!
Yeah.
Oh, I think it's open.
Oh wait, no, it didn't save.
We didn't save it.
I don't...
I don't think we need that door.
We know how to go outside.
That's true.
I think it would be good to open it though, just in case.
Alright, okay, okay, so...
This door?
Alright.
Is there anything else in here?
What do we have to do in?
There is a place!
Oh!
In here!
Everybody left.
If you...
If you lose an item, like the flashlight or something, you can...
You can get it back in that room.
Oh yeah, there's a thing!
Wait, which room?
I've got the door.
Oh, nice!
Alright.
In this room, see?
Oh!
Yeah.
Alright, will we save?
We just save Doobie.
Yeah, yeah, let's save Doobie.
Alright, we know how to go outside now.
Yeah, yeah.
We know.
Okay, so...
Where the fuck did you go, Nimi?
How did you go, Nimi?
She ran!
I couldn't find the...
I couldn't find...
The third floor.
Oh wait, we can go first.
I don't know where to go.
Okay, following you.
It's like forward and right.
Damn it.
Okay, who died?
Uh...
There was always three of us, right?
Uh-oh.
The other thing is there.
I think...
Nimi went, uh, forward from here and then right...
Yeah, yeah, I don't know where she was.
Oh, she's the only one that knew where to go!
She was the only one!
Uh-oh.
Yeah, see?
He's just friendly.
Oh, we found it.
Nice.
Good job, Doobie.
There's a guy right here, though.
He's right here.
Just run!
It'll kill one of us!
It'll kill me!
I don't wanna die!
I'm already dead!
Please!
I died once!
I think there's also another guy in here.
There were the little inky guys in here.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We'll...
Let's just find a save point.
Yeah.
Ow!
There's a really loud sound in here!
Yeah, I heard it.
Oh!
I am going!
It's me.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, world!
Goodbye!
Don't lock me out.
No, I think...
She found a save point!
Ah!
There's inky's!
She's trying...
She's trying to save!
She's trying so hard to save!
Where are you, Doobie?
Doobie!
This way?
Doobie, we don't know where the save is!
We're inky!
Maybe in the computer room.
I'm gonna...
Oh, you guys alive?
Yeah, yeah.
We saw you spamming the save.
Ah!
There's a save right here!
Save, save, save!
Okay.
Yay!
Oh my gosh!
How could you forget?
I was only gone for two minutes!
When you're scared, we start forgetting.
What's this?
Oh, wait, that's how you remove the...
Someone's...
Is it?
There's a...
There's a monitor man.
Oh, hey!
TV head.
Oh, I'm a TV head.
I don't think he...
Oh, he's friendly?
Oh, chat wants to...
An orange to replace...
Oh, he wants an orange!
Oh, nice!
Oh...
Uh...
Orange?
Signals on...
The brightness of the monitors need to be changed.
Okay.
Don't make chat angry.
We gotta get rid of the black liquid.
Why are they sending you here?
I saw a monitor.
I picked one up.
They said we gotta, like, make it match.
Hmm.
Does anybody else have a monitor?
What?
Uh...
No, I don't have another one.
I saw one.
Um...
In another room where we hid.
Oh, yeah!
I remember that, yeah.
It's, like, right over here.
My sandwich is too peanut buttery.
Right here.
Will this work?
Yeah.
Maybe?
See?
Oh, I think this is the lick.
This is the goo.
I think.
Yeah, we have to remove it.
The fact that you can see the monsters, like, climbing around outside is pretty freaky.
Netherboard.
Oh.
I'm lost.
Um...
Is this what you want, sir?
Fairly.
How do I...
Wait.
What do I do with my flashlight?
What else have to do next?
Wait, did you place a monitor?
I'm strong.
I didn't have a monitor.
I have a monitor?
Wait, where do I place it?
Right here.
Okay.
Maybe there's the cat.
Oh, gosh.
I dropped it for the monitor.
Wait, isn't that?
There he is.
Yeah, yeah.
There's also an evil centipede.
It's coming our way.
It's okay.
It's like a little rat.
Oh, guys, I don't think this monitor match.
Are you sure?
I think it's fine.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go get my flash...
Wait, I can get another flashlight here, right?
A wall of flashlight this way.
There is like a house somewhere.
But follow me, guys.
There's a hole with a monster.
A hole with a monster.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Green electrical.
Electrical.
Oh, um...
There was a red line like a...
Oh, okay.
Can we just put it...
Can we just put this in here?
Oh, we can't.
No, that's the trading machine.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
We have to hold on to this then.
Okay, I found like...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Follow me, guys.
There's a little hole...
With a...
With a monster.
I have nothing in my hand.
I'm serious.
I'm gonna check the red line.
Okay.
Did you just sit?
Why are you so scared?
You sat down.
Don't look at the goo monster.
I'm okay.
I need a moment.
Oh, nice.
We gotta go revive...
Doobie.
Whoa!
Oh, there's a puzzle!
We're gonna get a gun...
Once we figure this out.
Hurry...
Silent Hill...
Wait, wait.
Doki!
Yeah?
Come...
We revive Doobie.
There we go.
Hello!
Alright, we gotta do this.
Oh...
One, two, three, four, five.
I got the left side.
Oh...
What do you mean?
What is it?
Is it the computers?
Yeah, if you turn one off...
Some of them turn...
No!
I got the left side.
You meant to do the right.
Yeah.
Oh, this is the gray.
Got it!
What?
Oh...
We do?
No...
Oh...
Great, great...
Wait...
Isn't that not gray?
Oh wait...
No, this has to be white.
Oh...
What if I do this?
This is...
Oh...
I thought they were all supposed to be...
It's different colors.
Oh, it's like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh...
And then this should be black.
This guy's funny looking.
And then...
Hello.
Hint to the puzzle.
Oh, he'll give us a hint.
Oh, nice.
What's he saying?
Oh...
Wait, what?
I think...
Oh gosh...
You need to...
Make the...
Signals...
Oh...
Okay.
They're like...
You just got matching.
Wait a minute.
Good hint, guys.
Follow the line!
Each line corresponds to a square!
Did you solve the puzzle?
This one?
I was gonna make...
I was gonna see if she was...
Alive.
What's down here?
This is the ghoul, right?
Yeah.
No!
This is the nether portal?
Is there anything...
There was this slot here, but...
Oh, nice!
Must not be the first one.
I hear something, like...
Whispering.
Hmm...
Oh, there's a hole!
There's a hole here!
Huh...
I guess if you need to loop the monster...
Oh...
Probably...
Hmm...
Someone's sounding like...
Spongebob...
Squarepants...
Around here.
You're right!
Oh, we got...
We got GooGuy again.
Yeah.
Oh, can we...
Get out this window?
It's open.
I feel like we can't jump.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can't...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, bad.
This one, too.
Oh, there you go.
Wait!
I see!
I see out here!
Look, Nemi, Nemi!
There's...
There's another electrical thing out there.
Yeah!
Interesting...
I don't know...
We did it!
Yay!
Can we save?
Let's save, let's save.
Oh, yeah, let's save, let's save.
Easy.
Save.
Yeah, we're the smart blondes.
Yeah, what are you guys doing, huh?
Where'd you guys go?
Yeah, we were getting map awareness.
We found an electrical box.
I heard you giggle.
Yeah, I heard you giggle.
That's right!
Work!
Shoot the...
Shoot the ink blobs.
I heard you giggling through the wall.
Shoot Inky.
Nah, they don't...
They can't be shot.
Oh.
Maybe they're tamed.
They're, like, domesticated.
Oh, yeah.
Domesticated chat.
They're well behaved now.
Look, look out here.
There's an electrical box on the rooftop there.
Oh.
We gotta find a way to get it.
Oh, yeah, okay.
No, I know how to get there.
I know how to get there.
But I wanna...
Shoot the shadows first.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's over here.
It's a lot scary when there's, like...
You know...
When there's light.
Yeah!
Oh, wow!
That actually worked!
Okay, but here...
Just follow me.
There's, like, another...
Look.
Follow me.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, did you get the goo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
This goes into the classroom.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Here, here, here.
This guy.
There's something evil out there.
Oh.
I can't shoot him.
Did that work?
No.
I think it's for...
I don't know what...
Oh.
It's just for the wall, right?
I think so.
I don't know what this is for, though.
There he goes.
It's for the wall.
Didn't we get the wall?
Yeah, no, no, the wall.
No, that's not the wall.
The wall's behind us.
Go!
Alright, well, let's go back then.
Yeah, we're back.
We have a wall to explore.
We've got a wall.
Yeah.
We've got a wall to explore.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll do that.
We'll do that for it.
Ah!
Oh.
Okay, so that's...
Meet the monster on...
Ah!
I think they met the monster.
Ah ha ha.
I met the monster.
Also, was there a Samurai?
If so, thank you so much!
Oh my god, are we safe?
Are we safe?
I'm coming back!
Green girls, go together.
I don't think you can come in here, right?
I think he's too sick.
Oh, close the door.
I don't think...
Hello?
Are we safe?
I don't know if we need to be safe.
I don't think so.
I know she's dead, dead.
I saw them both get run over, like they both got hit with a bus.
Oh, okay, so we have to like run past it when he...
Yeah.
I don't remember where the wall...
Oh, there's a door here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
He's so loud!
He really does sound like a boss.
Okay, when he does the loop, we run.
Oh!
Let me!
We have to wait for him to do the loop.
I heard her for a split second.
She's like an angel.
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, yeah, you're safe in there, you're safe in there.
An alarm clock.
Um...
Doobie?
Doobie is still alive.
Doobie, though?
It really is like a train.
Chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-choo-choo!
The train...
is departing.
Kinda cute.
Wait...
How did Doki die?!
Oh god, I'm not gonna make it.
Doki, how did you die?!
I don't know why I can't ever hear anybody when I'm dead.
I... I can't...
How did Doki die?
I'm gonna eat my sandwich.
It's a peanut butter banana sandwich.
I wonder if this is useful.
Oh, it's so much peanut butter.
Hello?
Is that a spirit box?
Hey!
That's my radio!
Is everybody dead?
Oh yeah, she can revive us.
Oh, she's back!
Yeah!
Hello!
Okay, so...
Um...
Um, so...
He turns around.
He does?
Yeah, so we have to let him walk, run a little bit, and then...
Uh...
Oh, you can have the gun.
Nah, it's okay.
Alright, and then like...
And then run.
So I was wondering how you died.
I tapped the doobie for two seconds.
Yeah.
I know, me too!
I missed...
He turns around.
I think we can run from here, right?
Maybe?
I just wait until he turns the corner.
Yeah.
Why is he so loud?
Go, go, go.
Run, run, run.
We're all gonna get...
Run, run, run, run!
Get the door!
Go, go, go!
I got the door, I got the door, I got the door, I got the door.
We're safe here, we're safe here.
Doobie?
Where's Doobie?
Oh yeah, oh wait, you're right.
No, I think that's probably an easier way to get the... Wait.
Doki, come back.
Doki, come shoot the goo.
Come shoot the goo.
Wait, where?
It's uh... What the?
Right here.
Right here, right here.
Oh.
Watch out!
I don't see a goo anywhere.
No, no, no.
What's there?
Out here, out here, out here.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Doki?
Me?
Wait, behind you.
There you go.
Oh, through the window.
Oh.
Through the window.
To the wall.
Okay, it's just me.
I got this.
Maybe.
Maybe I don't.
If I die... I've been dead.
I don't like it the way it breathes.
It's so scary.
That's what it sounds like.
It's huffing and puffing.
If you're so tired, stop running.
Bozo?
Gosh.
Please leave me alone.
Please.
Oh,
you got it?
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
Vince found the... Oh.
Oh.
Ah.
He's
gonna...
I saw... I saw Nimi dying to the... to the... to the... to the... to the...
Slender Man.
So I ran back inside.
The timing was bad.
I made it.
I got it!
Okay!
Okay, we got the door!
You got the windows?
Careful, don't get run over!
I'm not!
We wait here!
Okay.
Okay?
I'm running.
I sound just like that thing.
Can I fall off the roof, you think?
A brain.
We need two more.
There's probably one over there.
Yeah, we should go back and save.
What's in here?
Is there anything in here?
Gosh, why is this so nerve-wracking?
Oh, there was one in here, I guess.
It's the heavy breathing.
I know, he's scary.
Like, stop running if you're so tired.
Yeah, stupid.
Doki, where'd you go?
I'm on the other side.
On the other side?
You died?
Ah, I can still hear her.
It turned around on Doobie.
I think we can go.
Can we go?
Uh-oh, it's too late.
Wait, where?
I think we're dead!
I'm dead!
I didn't see the open door!
Okay, maybe it's a good thing I died, huh?
Yeah.
This game is insane!
Oh my gosh, it's only been an hour and a half!
It feels like it's been, like...
Like a year, we've been playing this game.
Oh wait, when did Doki die?
Okay!
We should've gone back and saved, huh?
We
should've gone back and saved.
Wait, does that mean she's dead?
The gun is right there?
I think so.
I'm gonna turn the light on, yeah.
Where's the save point?
You remember, Nimi, you remember!
Remember who you are...
And where the save point is...
I can do this on my own!
Yes, you can!
She's so cute.
Wait, what's in there?
You did it!
I became a hero!
Where are we?
Where is this?
Wait!
How did you get here?
Is that a green...
No?
Oh wait, I think this is where the...
The guy...
Crashed through the wall from.
Oh!
Okay, we're still...
Oh, I found a circuit!
Guys, guys!
Oh, circuit!
Nice, nice, nice!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Alright, we need to find one more circuit area.
Wait, it seems that monster that was hiding...
In the building is lurking on...
Oh...
Now it's broken loose.
I only have...
I can't pick it up because I have guns.
Oh, sorry!
Oh!
I got it!
Alright...
We have to figure out where this goes.
Uh...
The red line.
Follow the red line.
Uh...
Wait...
Are we going?
I don't know, I'm scared to go!
I'm scared too!
This thing is so ugly!
Go, go, go!
It's safe here!
Uh...
Is it here?
No, no, no.
This is the door.
Oh, okay, okay.
So we have to find...
Where to put the green.
Okay.
We have to make clear for a decision.
Yeah.
Okay, and then make sure he doesn't turn around.
Turn around!
Yeah, we can turn around and fucking...
Go, go, go!
In here?
Maybe.
I don't think I saw one in here, but maybe.
I mean, we can crouch here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There's no line in here.
Come on.
Yeah.
Where the fuck is the line?
Where's the line?
There's a line here.
Let me in.
He's going to turn around again.
What?
There's no line.
I don't see a box here.
I don't either.
I don't even feel free.
Oh wait.
I should follow them.
A w-A wait?
A wait?
Is dubio...
Oh, I was wondering that too.
Turn around!
Actually, don't turn around.
Okay.
Oh my God, I thought he turned around for a second.
What's that sound?
Can we respawn them?
Wait, what's...
Where am I putting it?
Oh, can I respawn do you?
I know where the box is!
Oh, there's more, there's more than one!
I think, I remember that giant jumping thing all the way over there?
Yeah, I think...
I think that's where the last green box is.
This probably is.
Wait, let's save real quick, let's save real quick since we put it in the box.
Okay, yeah, we just did that one, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
We're gonna see the mood, guys!
We're gonna see the mood!
The mood!
Alright, we wait to a rocket.
Alright!
Oh my god, oh my god, we're gonna see this to a rocket.
We're gonna go to space with our anime girlfriend.
Yeah.
We win!
I'm gonna run to the safe spot.
Safe point.
Alright.
Okay.
I feel very safe in here.
I'm gonna take the radio, then.
Yeah.
Put on some gas, doobie!
What?!
Um...
I think I died...
How the hell did I die?!
Because we're a team!
We're right...
Sorry!
What did you do?
My kissy.
We all ran out!
We let him just turn around with all kinds of things!
I think like, the collision of your bodies...
Because I didn't go outside, I think it like ran into me.
What did I do?
Go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Hahaha!
Fucking lemons, yeah!
The four for one sale!
There you go.
There we go.
Okay.
The four for one sale.
Hahaha!
Go, go, go!
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna make it!
We're gonna
make it!
Doobie!
I think we're way past 19.
Okay, the last green circuit is here.
It's got to be.
Wait what if the radio is the key?
I don't think the radio is...
Where is the radio?
Oh, wait, where's Doobie?
He died because of the radio.
What if the sound distracts it?
Alright, do it.
Oh, he ran away.
Go off the way.
Alright, I thought we should sit close together.
It sounds like a cat.
It sounds like that cat that's eating.
I don't want to die again!
I don't want to die!
Alright, well we can't sit together because we got...
I don't think he sees us.
You're fine, he didn't see us.
Be a hero.
But where is it?
He's gonna jump soon.
I know, but I don't know where...
It's fine, we're fine here.
Wait, wait we distracted for Nimi, we distracted for Nimi!
Yeah, yeah.
AHHH.
We did not distract him.
No, she's alive, she's alive!
Yeah, she's alive, she's alive.
Did she get it?
She's a hero.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go before someone else dies.
Watch the Slenderman come back and get one of us.
Wait, no man, you hold it.
But you know where it is.
You know where it is.
Okay, we gotta wait for the loop.
We gotta wait for...
Alive!
Heroes!
Oops.
Uh, there we go.
I'm gonna die.
I made it!
I lived!
Yeah,
we should save again, for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
There's a door.
It's a loop right here.
Oh, we should go this way then.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's on the other side.
It's on the other side of the...
Oh, wait.
It's the door.
We gotta go all the way down.
Yeah, that's right.
Wait, where are they?
I don't know.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Where are we going?
It's the left side.
No, it's...it's...it is, but...
We gotta go down this hallway first.
Alright, I'll see it before.
Oh.
Hey, where are you guys?
I'll be the first one there.
There.
Okay.
It's like...
Right here!
It's right here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Nice, alright.
Woohoo!
We did it!
Yeah!
We defeated the monster!
Where's the moon?
Wait, what's down here?
Hello?
Uh, close from the other side.
Okay.
Hi, mom.
No.
No, we can't open that.
No, no, no.
Can we go down then?
Down, down, down.
Oh, there's another one here.
River!
Dynamite?
Ooh.
Any dynamite here?
For that monster.
I'm shooting my goo.
That's right, shoot that white goo.
Wait, yeah, we gotta place...
Oh, elevator!
Oh, there's a door!
There's a door!
Where's a safe boy?
It's your wife!
It's your wife, Ben!
Where?
You made it!
See, I...
Are you heading to the board?
Step back.
I'm gonna...
What does it say?
I'm coming!
Whoa!
That's my woman!
I couldn't help it!
She's coming with us!
She's so tall!
You gotta impress her with your moves!
I know.
Oh, yeah, hold on.
Let me show her.
Come here.
Wait, where's she going?
You see that?
Oh!
Let's all dance around here.
Yeah.
Let me jump down the elevator chair.
Oh, she's in here.
Woo!
Which one is that?
Wait!
Do you think she likes it?
I'm doing a robot here.
That's not the robot.
That is the Macarena.
Someone has to press the elevator.
Alright, next.
Oh my god, her hair when we go down.
Wow!
This elevator is fast, guys.
The fastest elevator ever, yeah.
Yeah.
Do we have to turn them?
This looks like a fried house.
Uh-oh.
Um...
There's some...
There's some creepiness over there.
Can you talk to her?
Oh, she doesn't want to talk to us.
She doesn't want to talk to you.
Oh, okay.
You talk to me.
It's just a dead guy.
No, but there's another guy.
It looks like a clown.
A clown?
Are you afraid of clowns, man?
Look at him.
He's got really long arms.
Where?
Oh wait, there is a clown.
Oh, it's...
It's...
Wait!
Oh, he trapped him!
They trapped him!
Oh!
Whoa.
I didn't know this was that kind of dungeon.
Yeah!
Wait, wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's his brother!
Yeah!
Dance number five on him!
Dance number five.
That's someone's brother!
Let it rip!
Someone's brother, yeah.
I'm bro!
Oh, no!
What does the bro have to say?
Nothing.
He's a silent killer.
There's a door over here.
Whoa!
Big room!
Boom!
Whoa!
How long is this game?
Will we ever see the moon?
Oh, we're here?
We're...
Wait.
She did kind of look like a banana.
Yeah, but then the guy died.
Oh.
We had to go downstairs.
We had to find...
Maybe...
A staircase?
Oh!
A scanner!
Oh, nice!
This guy!
I just...
Oh, I think that's him!
Where are you guys?
Oh.
Why is she telling you, Juby?
It's a...
mandatory scam...
You guys don't need to watch this, guys.
You're the...
You know, like the...
We're the movie inspectors.
I'm just trying to see what the scan thing does.
Oh.
Wait!
Can I just push the third button on the elevator?
Wait.
Okay.
Who forgot to push the other button?
Who...
Who forgot to push the third button?
I didn't realize there was a basement three.
Oh!
Whoops!
Sorry.
That was...
Whoa!
Our guesses were correct!
The moon is locked in here!
Are we giant...
We need to find a way to free it!
We're in Bruce's laboratory, guys!
We're in Bruce's laboratory!
There's a cat down there.
What's the cat?
Oh, yeah!
The cat's staring at the moon!
What's that thing?
Oh, is that our girl?
Is that our girl right there?
Oh, there she is!
Yeah!
Did you want to see the moon?
I caught the moon for you!
So this is the moon you are after?
Cute, but kind of tiny, isn't it?
Oh, it's not about the size.
The worst she can say is no.
Some people say it's above average, okay?
Wait, do you guys see the little coronaviruses that are downstairs?
What did she have?
Did you see anything?
Where?
I
can't do it, I can't do it again.
I got my shot.
I toggled it.
Oh, something happened.
I mean, I don't think it's dangerous right now.
Okay.
Okay, let's just explore.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, TVs are coming on.
Oh, yeah.
I see it.
There's no elevator here.
You know how to use that thing?
No, I don't.
Call the elevator.
No, it just shoots off in the mud.
Look at it.
Ooh, white liquid gun.
I'm controlling it.
Wait, you're controlling?
Yeah.
Oh, cool.
Is that all we do here?
It's an elevator.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we go in?
Is it?
It says first, second, and third.
Oh.
Hmm.
What else could we need around here?
I got one of those.
Don't say that.
Oh, yeah.
Electronic board.
Zero out of two.
We gotta get an electronic board.
Oh, so we're going to the elevator.
We're going to the elevator, yeah.
Yeah.
It's just shooting it on its own.
Someone might need it.
It's Bluetooth wireless.
Oh.
Wait, do we need it?
Yeah, we might need it.
I'll take it.
Get out of here.
I don't like it.
Ew, I can't control it.
No, I mean, Doobie's controlling it.
I know, but it's in my hands.
Okay, so dude, what floor do we do?
We need electric boards is what it said.
We need two of them.
Okay.
Is this an electric board?
I think so.
Is that it?
It's a scanner.
It's a board.
Oh, look.
Yeah, we're on a different floor, so...
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is where the monsters are.
Wait.
I think this is a save point, guys.
Oh, nice.
Finally.
Save it.
Okay, nice.
There's something appearing on my radar.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, maybe that finds the electric boards.
Wait, maybe it's the moon.
It's the moon.
Oh, I see it.
COVID's coming.
Oh.
Wait, wait.
War 2019.
Tell them COVID's coming.
Can I shoot it?
Oh.
My aim.
Oops.
A little down.
Were you able to shoot your waiku on it?
I'm trying to.
I have performance anxiety.
Or we go forward.
Wait, there's something over here.
Is that...
I just toggled something.
I don't know what happened, but...
Oh, I found a...
Oh, I found a lever!
Oh, wait.
I think we have to do it at the same time.
The gate to the lower floor is locked by multiple levers.
They must be activated simultaneously?
What?
Oh, no.
Okay, I have a lever for one of them.
Are there four levers?
There's no way.
But how would we...
Wait.
I guess they stay activated once you...
You think they're lethal?
They do everything like that.
These things?
Yeah.
COVID.
Oh, no.
Wait, there's little...
Oh, they're little guys!
They have little heads!
What is that?
Okay, it doesn't work.
Look at them.
They're walking.
Mutation.
It wasn't me, guys.
Oh, it was on purpose.
So maybe I should find a lever and then I'll press the...
Oh.
Did you make...
Did you make it angry?
Yeah.
Wait, is there a lever over there or...?
I have a lever.
Yeah, there is.
There is.
Mimi's not a lever.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Then...
You have that one and then I have probably the one upstairs.
Right?
What?
Oh.
You have to go back?
Wait,
I'll shoot the gun.
I'll shoot the gun when she...
Don't press it yet.
She said she'll shoot the gun when Nimi presses it.
Oh, okay.
You think...
Not yet.
Um...
Almost?
You think the Bluetooth range fell off?
Oh!
Press it!
Did it work?
No.
There must be another lever because I have this.
Oh, remember there's the one upstairs.
I think that someone has to go...
Yeah, but...
Does that have to...
Also?
Yeah, I think so.
It didn't work!
There's more levers!
Nimi died!
Yeah, I mean, he's dead.
Oh.
I think...
I think he died.
Well, let's just go back upstairs and we got it anyway.
There's the same area here.
Oh, oh, that's right.
It's this...
It's this floor.
Just kidding.
I think...
Is Doobie dead?
Oh!
Yeah.
We did turn on the lever.
It didn't work.
Yeah.
Is there another lever down here?
Because I do have...
Uh...
I do have an apple.
Well, wait.
Let's go check the third floor, too, then.
Because it might be down there.
I'll be in the coordinate, like, all four, though.
Yeah, don't you need everyone to be in the elevator to use it?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's coming in this...
Ahh!
Ah, he's a little coward baby.
Yeah.
We got our shots.
Yeah, we got our shots.
Yeah.
Scary.
That was like we're animals.
We got our... we got our flea shot.
Yeah!
Oh no!
It went after Nimi!
Uh-oh.
Did she make it?
I don't know.
It's making that sound like...
I think she's... Oh, she ran to the other side.
Yeah.
You made it!
Let's just take the third floor then, for now.
Yeah, let's go... Okay, I got four levers.
Let's go down one more...
I'm just gonna hold on to this lever then.
Yeah.
Well, I guess... Yeah, first floor.
Hey!
You guys, it works without everybody being in the elevator.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
Yeah, then we can pull all of them.
Yeah, but how do we do the countdown?
Time to split up, gang.
Take a time, and then do it up when the clock...
Oh!
Let's get our alarm!
Let's set up an alarm!
Oh, yeah!
What is that?
What is this?
Yeah, this is what I saw before...
Oh, wait!
She's a minion.
It's a little guy!
Oh, there you go!
Oh, there's a broken lever!
Here you go!
Documentation for the crystal.
The crystal made from an orange.
It glows with a bright orange pattern and emits orange particles that gradually fade away.
When the moon remains indoors for an extended period, a residual heavy influence accumulates at the bottom of the room, aiding the ripening of oranges.
However, it can be lethal.
Even in a protective suit.
Wait, is this an orange?
Orange!
Oh, we gotta bring this to that guy!
If you need to approach the area beneath the moon, please take the crystal with you and stay close to it.
Okay, so you gotta take it.
Ew!
It's my hat.
What do you do?
Ew!
I'll get him!
This is an orange!
Has the gun always been in this position when you hopped?
Um...
I don't know.
He's just very excited.
Alright, so we have on the left...
How do we...
Aren't we gonna do the countdown for this?
Let's do it at 6 and 6.
It shows a light.
It shows a light when someone presses it.
Oh, yeah!
So we can just...
Oh, see the light.
Yeah, see it up!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I call bottom floor.
Okay.
We have to go to the COVID one.
And this will save us from COVID.
Alright, I'll do the first one.
I'll do the first one.
Bye!
Um...
I could...
I don't care which one I go to.
Wait, how many are there?
Do we even count?
Two?
Yeah, there's four.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I'll go to...
You're gonna go to the top one?
I could go to...
Wait, there's two on this one.
There's two?
Yeah.
Go to my girlfriend, then.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go test this, uh...
Crystal.
Okay.
So brave, Doki.
It did say that it's lethal, so I hope she doesn't die.
Oh, she's already pulled it.
I thought I heard something.
It's so scary.
What am I...
Oh.
Alright, we're all...
We're all good.
Okay.
Pull!
Oh, I see the crystals.
Uh...
What is that?
Maybe not good.
Call the element.
Okay.
No problem.
I'm...
I'm waiting.
Why is she screaming?
There we go.
La, la, la, la.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Bah.
Maybe we should've gone and saved bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah.
Bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah.
Goin' to the first floor.
Ah, man.
Let's go.
Stay in the orange.
Okay.
Or we die.
We're going this way.
There's a cat.
He's so cute.
Yeah.
What's this?
What is that?
Electronic.
Oh, one of the boards we need.
It's a motherboard.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Relax.
Run, run.
What?
Yeah, you guys got to get the board again.
Someone dies to the moon.
I heard the boom sound.
Yeah, I'm over there.
Can you not see me?
I hope this... We got to find a save.
I'm pretty sure it has to be.
The save is on the second floor.
Oh, Easter egg.
There's an egg.
There's an Easter... Oh, no.
There's another one.
Wait.
Oh, there's more.
I died.
Vine boom.
The vine... Not the vine boom.
What is this?
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, they're gathering?
There's three of them now.
There's three.
One for each of us.
Uh-oh.
Doki about to die.
The moon virus.
Oh, no.
They're going to take our bodies.
You're going to get... What if it's... What if it's like... We got to find a save before they kill us.
It's the stench aura.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's up the stairs.
It's all stairs.
Oh, yeah.
Let's go up the stairs.
Yeah.
The aura.
Okay.
I don't think they can go upstairs.
I don't think so, too.
They don't have to lose.
Oh, there's the same.
Oh, Nez.
Bring me home.
Let's go.
I'm home.
Oh, they can go up the stairs.
Oh, man.
So what happened?
The moon virus got you?
Yeah, I got got by the moon virus.
At least we saved.
We're getting... We're getting killed by an inflatable man.
We're going to die by the... Oh, the moon virus... The moon virus has infected us here.
Oh.
Well, that would have been great to know.
Us green girls, we got... Look at the alien.
The fully red, orange, as far as the new healer should take hold of it.
What the... What's that?
It's a little... It's the alien from... From Mexico.
Hello.
Hello, chat.
Hello?
Is he still chasing you?
Oh.
Welcome back, everyone.
Hello.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
What is this?
Place for capsule.
We got to get the capsule in.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope Push it down there.
Push it with all my strength.
Right there, right there, right there.
There.
Okay, we gotta push the other one.
We gotta push the other one.
It was over on the other side.
I remember.
Wait, wait, let's all get Doobie back guys!
Guys, guys.
Doobie!
Yeah, yeah.
Get Doobie back.
Doobie!
Hello!
Welcome back Doobie!
Welcome back!
There's also a capsule downstairs, but I don't know.
I think that's probably it.
I don't think we can all land the stairs.
No, yeah, we can push this one.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
He's right there, he's right there, he's right there!
Run for your lives!
Oh, shoot.
The squeaky, oh gosh, he's covered in PVC.
He's covered in latex.
This is sexy!
I do not consent.
Is everyone dead?
Hello, oh.
Oh, I just watched Nimi die.
Yeah, let's rez him.
Hello.
You're almost pulling back.
Oh, shoot, I need to...
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Oh, God.
Wait.
Oops.
I'm gonna die!
Die!
I forgot that we need the orb to go downstairs.
So that's Doobie's job.
Thank you, everybody's there.
Yeah, we are.
Yeah,
we are.
Doobie has to push it up all the way here.
Yeah, I know.
That's a lot.
Hopefully she...
Wait, if she dies, the orb stays down there.
No, no, there's a train here.
Oh, okay, just kidding.
There's a...
There's a guy behind him, he's behind him.
Run!
Go ahead!
Latex man!
Bondage guy!
It's the invisible man from the movie.
Do you hear, like, how squeaky he is?
Yeah, he is.
It's the invisible man.
Invisible...
Oh, look at Doobie.
Do you see Doobie?
Look at her go, inching her way up.
With the little...
With chat behind her.
She's doing it.
Run!
Let's distract him!
Oh yeah, that's true, we have to distract him.
Oh my god, I think we're distracting him.
Okay, let's hope Doobie is.
Where is he?
Just pushing him.
Oh!
Where is he?
Oh, I see him.
I'm gonna go this way.
He's right behind you.
I don't see him.
Where is he?
I hear him.
Oh, there he is!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I hear his sexy suit.
Oh, Doobie, what's going on?
Oh, uh, can you get...
Go stand on the stairs and then push this thing?
Alright, now...
Ah, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Sorry.
Where's the latex man?
I think Nimi is distracting him.
Alright, we're pushing.
Slow and steady.
Almost there.
Right here, right here.
Push, push.
Push.
Dance.
Yay!
Now what?
Got the dynamite!
Oh!
So we got...
Where was that?
Oh my God, where was that?
It was the third...
It was like...
We have to go back through the basement.
Yeah.
Insert the electrical board, open the hatches.
Save, save, save, save, save.
Leave the laboratory and blow up...
Oh my God!
I'm...
Insert the electrical boards, open the...
What?
Wait...
Huh?
Insert the electrical boards, open the hatches.
Where's that guy going?
Do we lead the lab before?
Instructions unclear.
I don't know.
Where's the electrical board?
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
We can get more crystals if we lose it.
I'm just looking at the other...
Oh yeah, yeah.
But we can't get more dynamite apparently.
Oh gosh.
Oh, in the PC room, you got the electrical board earlier?
Where's PC room?
It looks like bacon.
Chat!
Maybe we just... Yeah, let's just leave.
Oh, wait.
Doobie!
Wait, Doobie!
I thought she was in it!
She's hanging out.
She's hang... Oh wait, I'm gonna die!
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Aw...
Okay, third floor.
She got moon.
Wait, we can revive her at the second floor.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Isn't it?
There's no revive on the third, right?
Mm-mm.
Alright, let's go to the second.
I don't remember.
Too much radiation from the moon.
Oh.
Is that what it is?
I guess?
Probably, right?
Too much orange.
In all the orange.
Yeah, yeah, and vitamin C.
Alright.
Okay!
How is it having the moon virus?
Better than having the COVID virus.
So true.
That's so cute.
Yeah, this one all you do is die.
There was a purple board from the bottom floor?
What?
Was there?
Did we get the one that was in the lab?
Somebody had one, right?
I don't remember.
I don't...
Who?
Someone was definitely carrying one around.
Oh, yeah, she left.
Oh, she left.
Oh, I know.
It was where?
Oh, gosh.
I died.
I...
Oh.
There was one.
Downstairs.
I died.
I was holding it.
Oh, okay.
Wait, give...
Okay, give us the diamond.
We'll give you the moon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait.
Min's gonna get one of the electrical guards.
It's downstairs.
She needs the vitamin C.
Yeah, I knew that.
There you go.
Take it.
We're playing soccer with it.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll come with you, cause like...
You can't hold it with two hands, remember?
Oh, you can't?
I don't know, actually.
I don't think so.
Well, come on.
Make sure you can't...
Alright, let's go.
We'll have to go anyway.
First floor.
So, where did you die?
I know where I died.
It was...
So, where was it?
It wasn't upstairs.
It was downstairs.
Okay, that's good.
That's easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait.
I'll hold the...
I'll hold the orange then.
Cause then you can grab the thing.
I'll hold the orange.
Come on.
Okay, then I'll have to hold the fucking electrical board.
Choose one or the other.
It's right here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's a fucking gun.
Oh, I got it.
Yeah.
Oh, you can hold one too.
See, I told...
You can hold up to three items.
Okay, I didn't know that.
I just got that.
I thought you can only hold one item.
Oh, I dropped all of them at the same time.
Okay.
Oh, good job.
Yay.
Oh, I see what she meant by the placement of the gun.
Yeah, right.
Oh.
You're making some people very happy right now.
We got one of the electrical boards.
Yeah.
I don't know what the other ones are though.
Where do we insert it?
Right here, right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where was the other one?
I don't remember.
There's only three more.
Yeah.
Chat!
Where are the other three?
Other three?!
Oh, this one says two here, but I think somewhere else...
Oh...
We didn't see anything, did we?
I don't know.
Don't remember.
Other three are outside.
Outside?
Other three are outside?
There's one...
One person.
One singular person.
The one guy.
Alright, do we need to get one guy?
Oh, somebody said there was one in the computer lab.
Do we trust that guy?
That one guy?
Oh, we have to bring the orange to him too.
The crystal.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Might as well, yeah.
Okay, let's go then, yeah.
Where does the dynamite go?
Isn't he gonna turn into like an evil creature though?
I know, I feel like that's gonna happen.
He's gonna be friendly.
Maybe he's gonna be friendly.
He's gonna join our party.
Okay.
We'll have five people.
Was it first floor?
Oh, was it first floor?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I wanna go back to the basement.
It was first floor and then we gotta go to the third floor.
Yeah, yeah.
I wanna get to the third floor.
Oh, we should save.
Oh, yeah, we should.
Um, where was the save for?
Okay, we have to go back to the running van.
Where's the save here, anyway?
I don't remember any of this.
This looks new to me.
Oh, here we go.
Put the diamond, yeah.
Oh.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Nice.
Okay, we did that.
There's definitely gonna be something in here.
There's a shortcut.
There's a shortcut, yeah.
Yeah, see?
Oh, it's just outside.
electrical boards are out here.
Oh, that's what the one guy said.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, guys, guys.
Where'd he go?
Oh my gosh, I see the slender man too.
Oh, that means the third floor is free.
Oh, we have to be even more careful out here.
She was in.
Oh.
Holy moly.
We open both doors now.
But what?
I think we can go like anywhere now.
Maybe the election floors are out.
Okay, wait.
That means the third floor should be like...
I don't think we should...
It's not dangerous anymore, right?
Yeah, but I don't think we should explore until we save.
Oh.
Yeah, we should save, yeah.
But where is the safe foot?
I don't know.
I saw slender man in the other building.
So I think we're safe here.
We changed his brother too.
Famous last words.
He likes stairs.
He does like stairs.
He's gross.
But he's gone.
Wait.
Doobie said she found it?
Oh.
Coming to the sound of your voice.
Oh, you're upstairs.
I'm downstairs.
Yeah, yeah, we're downstairs.
Downstairs?
Downstairs.
Oh, yeah, there.
I see.
Where?
Right here.
Oh.
Yay.
Okay.
Now we can explore.
Okay, now...
Let's go to the TV room because the monster's not here anymore.
Look behind you.
Oh my god.
Okay, there's that guy though.
Let's go to the TV room.
Third floor.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Third floor, third floor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We went up the...
Mimi and I went up and the monster was gone.
Nice.
It was like here.
Oh, yeah, here.
Here we go.
Da da da da da da.
Oh, we did it guys.
We liberated the third floor.
Yay!
We're doing, but we're doing it.
We are.
We're giving them the orange.
I have.
I know, but I just mean in general.
Like, what are we doing?
I have PTSD of these hallways.
After we found the moon.
Oh, look.
Oh, that's how he broke out.
Yeah, he...
What the heck is that mustache eyeball?
This school is weird.
I don't...
I don't know who it is.
We're saving the moon.
That's right.
Oh, where is he?
TV man.
Oh, there he is.
Look.
I got an orange for you.
Yeah.
Hey, hi.
Oh.
Hey.
Who are you?
I'm a TV head.
That guy, look at his body.
He's definitely going to turn into...
Yeah.
I have a TV instead of a head.
But I'm...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
This is all the same thing.
Does he want it?
Does he not want it?
Is he just here for storytelling reasons?
Wait, he doesn't want the orange?
Maybe it's the wrong one.
Wrong orange.
Nah.
Okay, then we'll just leave it here.
We don't need it, I think.
Yeah.
That's safe.
Safe.
Safe anyway.
Alright, so we go outside.
Ta- I'm gonna fall from the third story.
Here I go!
Wait, is that an electrical panel right...
Wait, you guys!
What?
I think there's an electrical panel down here.
Yeah, I see it.
Do you think it touches?
Of all those baby hands?
No, I think that one is...
Oh, wait!
I can't fall...
I can't walk out the door.
No, no, that's like the fence.
You see that fence over there?
That's where we exploded the dynamite.
Yeah, I know, but I thought I would be able to fall.
No, you can't.
Dang.
You can't do a flip.
I tried jumping off earlier.
Alright, it's this way.
Down we go!
Doodoo.
Boodoo.
Oh, too many.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Grab that one electrical panel.
Where?
There's something evil here.
Oh, no!
It needs it!
It needs two of them!
What?
Two?
Yeah.
Oh, wait!
So this is where the other one is, I guess.
Yeah!
Oh, the other two!
Oh, this is the top of the same laboratory.
Yeah!
This door.
What's this mustache?
You think that...
I found a shortcut!
Oh, shortcut!
Oh, nice!
Let's go!
Silent Hill moments?
This is where we met our wife.
Oh, yeah, we're here!
And the kitten!
I missed that kitten.
Okay.
Maybe the electrical board is on the other side.
Remember, there's...
There's that side, too.
Hmm...
Nothing in here.
This is where we put in the password.
Uh-oh.
I lost everybody.
My friends.
My friends!
No!
Let me know!
Oh, okay.
Look
how Nimi's infected body chased after you.
That was pretty freaky.
Safe point over here?
You would say she's...
My nightmare.
Let's go...
Let's go to safe point.
Where's safe point here?
Are you sitting?
Wait, you can sit here?
Yeah.
Just, you know, thinking.
Just thinking.
It's been a long night.
Like, you can take a little breather, right?
Yeah.
I'm also gonna...
I'm gonna do something to relax.
Take the nerves off.
Yeah.
I hear that.
That's for us.
Yes.
Yeah.
This is just how I think, you know?
At least in some stress, you know?
Me too.
Yeah, I feel that.
I gotta do a little flip to feel better.
I just witnessed my friend's death in front of my eyes.
There's a safe point over here.
I forgot.
Isn't it by the basement?
Like this way?
Yeah, I think.
Oh, the other way.
Other way.
Is the basement.
Oh, wait.
There's...
No, yeah.
By the basement.
There should be like one more.
I can't remember.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
You're right, Doobie.
You're right.
There's the easier one.
Sorry.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah.
Always listen to the others.
It was this right here.
Yeah, here.
Found it.
Sorry.
All right.
Welcome back.
Hello.
You like that we danced on top of your dead body?
Yeah.
It was a way to grieve.
I thought it would have passed into the afterlife.
So, congrats.
Tell me about it.
What can I do for you today?
Um, I'm looking for an electrical panel.
Yeah.
Oh, I...
I think it's somewhere like on the left side.
I'm thinking like over there.
Oh, I see it.
Um, do you recommend me some restaurants nearby?
Yeah, we haven't...
There's no...
Maybe we're robots.
Just like that robot was...
Oh, what are we just...
Oh, what are we just driving?
Probably wise.
Where are they now?
Wait, where are you guys going?
We have to go out this way.
We do?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Remember when the...
Did you look at the walk through?
Yeah.
The area where he died.
Oh.
Yeah, it was like...
Right here.
Okay, you go first.
You got the flashlight.
He's camping.
He's spawn camping.
He is.
Okay, she's gone.
Let's...
Let's revive her, I guess.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Did I go the...
I went the wrong way, sorry.
I'm just blindly following.
Yeah, me too.
That's fine.
I'll lead you to greatness.
He's right...
Guys, he's right behind me.
Oh, wait.
Wrong way, sorry.
Don't follow me.
He's here now.
What?
He's here, he's here.
Where?
Oh, he's here.
Yeah, he's here.
He's directly in front of us, outside.
Okay, so we should be able to go now.
What if there's more than one?
There might be.
I think there's only one.
There could be more than one.
Wait, do we go here?
I think...
He's right there.
Am I getting chased?
No.
Okay.
What's that scary music?
I think it's like...
Caterpillar.
We actually been here.
What about...
That was where the...
That was the cafeteria that...
Where we opened...
Um...
When we had to go outside...
There's like that second floor room with all the monitors.
I feel...
Have we been in there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here.
Where do we go now?
Open the gates to the surrounding area.
Uh...
Okay, there's a cat in there.
Oh, same point!
Our girlfriend!
Oh, there she is!
Strangeline.
Oh.
Oh, I found another oak gate.
Are you planning to go inside the annex?
Are we?
Uh...
Yes.
You know, there...
There were others before you.
Stop talking to me!
Similar to...
I'm learning the lore!
Many of them went there.
But I haven't seen anyone who came back from there.
Even though you see...
I don't wanna stand around the corner!
Oh, okay.
Oh, I've tried.
She disappeared!
Ah!
Like...
Like how we're all spamming.
Wait, we're going into a new building!
That's why.
Oh...
We're going here?
Yeah, the annex.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I don't like it.
I don't wanna...
I hear somebody...
I hear somebody breathing.
Me too.
I don't see anything on my scanner.
Wait...
Maybe he's gone...
Yeah, he's gone.
Maybe he just...
He got scared away.
From us?
Haha, we're a bunch of baddies.
It looks like he's...
It looks familiar.
It does look a little familiar.
But the doors aren't open.
Right?
Okay.
I hear somebody breathing.
I don't see anything on the scanner.
Oh wait, is it the other...?
Wait, one, two, three... This is one.
Me.
Oh, explore the annex.
Okay.
Is this the annex?
Yeah, but there is a breathing man in here.
Oh, hello.
Uh-oh.
That's her eggs!
The magic tells you not to worry about.
Oh, we just watched our comrade die in front of our faces.
Oh, um... Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Does that do me?
Oh...
I think that was do me.
Is it gonna open that door?
Oh, hello.
Hey.
Hi.
Oh, hey.
I think it's just us.
Did Doobie die?
Yeah, I watched her die.
Oh, that's like how it approached Nimi from behind.
Yeah, I know.
Wait.
Hello?
Did you hear that?
Oh, Nimi!
Nimi, you're alive?
I'm alive.
I unlocked the door somewhere.
Wait, how did you do this?
I thought I killed you?
I ran.
Oh!
What?
She's... Gamer.
Oh, so I almost... Go, run, run, run with you.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
I don't think you can open doors.
Uh... Okay, I feel like none of us closed the door.
Um... Well, you know... It is what it is.
What's this guy gonna say?
Nothing?
It's a silent protag.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him walking outside.
Yeah, me too.
But he goes around, though.
Yeah.
One of the capsules is located in the... How big?
Ouch!
How long is this game?
I don't know!
After we opened the laboratory, we... We saw the bed!
Just pick it up with our hands!
I don't hear him.
Should I open it?
Oh.
Okay.
I think we're... We're fine.
I don't know where to go, guys.
I don't know either.
You don't have the flashlight on.
Let me sweat.
Is everybody alive?
I'm alive.
Are you alive?
Yeah, I would come to you, but he's like, right outside the door.
Can you guys hear her?
He's like, right outside.
Maybe?
Barely.
Me too.
Hello?
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Ducky!
I can't get over there.
He goes through doors.
He does?!
He does!
He does.
Oh, shit!
SHIT!
SH
Oh!
What are you like?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, he jumps at you.
He lunges.
I was like, oh.
I'm sorry.
I can't help it.
Oh, sorry, Neme.
This guy's insane.
Wait, is she still alive?
I can just hear her laughing.
Oh, I can hear you.
Oh.
I can...oh.
Our voices come out of the thing.
We're back.
Okay.
This guy is kind of insane.
Yeah, but look at him jumping.
I know.
You can't... You're doing a good job like, uh, dodging him.
Yeah, you know what, Doki, what if you act as the bait and we'll push.
You were so good at dodging him.
Alright, yes.
Okay, here, here, here.
Push here, push here, push here.
Push?
It's in here.
Push here and then you push out from here.
In the front.
Don't worry, guys.
He's here!
He's coming!
Run!
He's behind us!
What is that?
Oh, he's on Nimi.
He's on Nimi.
Let's push it.
You're getting in a corner!
Oh my god.
I got scared.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Okay, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Push.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
I just saw Nimi.
Oh, there she is.
Nimi, Nimi!
Okay, okay, that's good.
We can push out, right?
Uh, she's no longer distracting him, so we don't know where he is.
I don't know where Doobie is.
Maybe Doobie's got him.
Doobie!
Oh my god, he's surprised.
He's surprised!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, go, go, go, go!
What is he?
I don't know!
Oh, wait!
Ooh, what's this?
This is a report from Squad 2.
The situation is strange, to say the least.
We found traces of Squad 1.
But what happened to them has left us in shock.
They're infected with something unknown.
Their bodies have changed, transformed into huge, terrifying monsters.
These aren't the people we once knew.
We're trying to figure out what happened.
In the meantime, we're returning our main objective.
The search for the moon.
Let's release the moon.
People are dying.
Is it us?
Are we dying?
Okay.
Sound safe.
I think so.
She's yelling a lot.
Are you pushing it?
I did it.
I did one of them.
But one of them is in the industrial building.
Okay, we gotta save.
We gotta go to the save point.
I'm gonna go to the save point.
Wait, but is Nimi and Doobie alive?
Uh, Nimi was last alive when I saw her.
Oh, okay.
Well, maybe she'll know to go if we click on it.
Save point!
Come to the save point!
We got save point!
Okay, okay.
Wait, how did you get there?
Um, Nimi's dead!
Or you could... or you could die.
Or...
Just... just... just die!
It's easier that way!
Okay, we're here.
I'll say...
Min said, wanted you to be dead.
I was like...
No, just so that we could revive easily, you know.
Okay, wait, where's the...
We have to check a different building, right?
Yeah, it says, what is in the industrial building?
Where the fuck is the industrial building?
How?
Yeah, push one of the capsules.
Where to find the other building?
Well... all the way!
How?
I don't know.
It looks industrial.
It does look industrial.
Does this look like...
Hello, are you the industrial building?
Oh, here we go!
Nice!
Oh, it is industrial!
Oh,
I hear a...
I hear a breathing man.
Report from Squad 3.
Oh, yeah.
This is complete disaster, guys.
Squad 2, teams, they've turned into some kind of monsters.
Moving on all fours.
And they look like...
Oh my god, they're enormous!
And we keep searching for those.
Because everyone...
Guys...
We decided to send one person northwest.
Let them try to find something, anything.
The rest of us are all falling back to the building and search for clues there.
Hopefully, this will work.
Over and out.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're better than that squad.
Yeah, we're squad.
We're Mickey 17.
Guys, there's three of them.
There's three of them.
Guys, there's four of them.
Four of them.
Oh!
He's coming!
It's not safe!
That guy just walked in!
It's his home!
Get down.
What is all this noise going on?
And there's a thingy behind you.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think the lizard guys...
Or the...
The worm guys kind of safe.
Doobie guy is friendly.
I think he sees us.
Oh shoot.
Oh no!
Did they both... did they die?
Did they get near me?
Was Doobie okay?
If I die, I die.
We need the gun!
Oh my god!
She's trying to save...
I'll just die.
Where are you?
The game has been saved.
Oh my god.
All I wanted to do was...
Free the moon.
I thought we were so close.
We're gonna do it.
It's possible.
We'll just get to 30 more minutes.
We can do this.
We can save the moon.
We need the gun.
There's... we need the... there's... there's goo.
There's goo wall.
Okay, okay.
So then we have to...
Wait, can we order it in here?
Yeah, yeah.
I think it was...
We can get it in here.
Yeah, we can get it in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Someone grab the goo gun.
Oh, I got it.
I think... can we enter through here?
Let me see.
I don't think so.
Wait, if you walk pretty close to them, it seems like they can't jump on you, so it's a little easier.
Oh no.
Yeah, it's in this building.
It's in here.
Okay.
I have yet to see one electrical board, guys.
I know.
Yeah.
It's worth doing.
Oh shoot.
I'm gaming.
What?
What did this lead to?
Oh shoot.
I found it.
I found the...
Wait.
Maybe if we push it out this way.
I found it.
Oh you did.
Did you shoot the goo?
Yeah, I shot it.
I think we got it.
I think it's easier if we push it through here.
That's probably what the goo gun was for.
Maybe?
Is there an exit?
Oh yeah, there we go!
Yay!
Push, push, push.
We can revive her.
We're right here.
Don't push it too far past the stairs.
You're back!
This is me watching Mint do her fucking heroic parkour One of the cats jumped on top of me.
Okay, I remember the deer guys in here.
It's to our right.
Wait, this way is faster.
This way is faster.
Okay.
Push it, push it, push it.
It's this way.
It means that he's kind of...
Push it, push it, push it, push it, push it.
Okay.
In here?
Maybe I see something upstairs.
I hear him.
Oh, this way?
In here?
Here.
He's coming.
He's coming?
Okay, one of us conveyed him.
Wait, you keep pushing because I don't know which way.
Do I go through the classroom or no?
You push and then left, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Look, look, look, look, look, look.
No, no, no, it's on the...
Oh, okay, that works too, that works too, that works too.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You should be calling him a stupid idiot.
You should try.
Oh, what'd we get?
Is this an electrical board?
I don't know.
Yes, it is.
I got electrical box.
Oh my God, we got electrical board.
Let's go!
Wait, is this too the thing though?
Wait.
This is electrical board, not electrical box.
That's what this is.
It's electrical box.
Keep right there, guys.
Keep right there.
We gotta go.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Oh, I- I went...
Oh.
I'm dead.
I'm dead!
I'm not dead, but I dropped the box.
Um, I'm not dead, but I dropped the box because I thought...
C'mon, I'm about to...
Um, c'mon, I'm about to...
Oh!
It's for me!
The box!
C'mon sot..
How'd you get it?
I don't know.
Wait, where do we put this box in?
Oh, I don't know.
Activate the elev- Oh, the elevator in the industrial building!
Put this boat in one of the industrial buildings.
Wait, how did you get that?
I don't know.
I dropped it in a dead end!
No, there was one.
Wait, so where's the other industrial building?
Oh, oh, oh, yep, yep.
Uh, aren't there three here?
There's four.
Yeah, I think there's...
Uh... Yeah, okay, so we gotta find one of the power supply and put this on.
Okay.
And one of the industrial buildings.
There's another goo wall!
There's another goo wall in front of us.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Let's grab the gun.
Um, where is it?
Oh.
Uh... Oh.
Oh, I got it.
Alright.
Nice.
Find the shovel.
Where did Nimi go?
See it right there?
Yeah, I got it.
Where's Nimi?
Oh my gosh, I have to be close to it.
Guys, what happened to Nimi, guys?
I'm in!
Oh, god!
Oh my
god, look what you did!
They're pretty aggressive now, they're pretty aggressive now!
I'm not gonna lie!
Oh my god, oh my god, Doobie's alive.
Doobie's alive.
Wait, Nimi has the shovel?
I think Nimi died.
No, wait, I think Nimi is alive.
Someone said she has the shovel.
Yeah, but maybe she died with the shovel.
No, she's alive!
She's alive!
We're all alive!
I was drinking my drinks!
Orange tree, orange tree right here!
Orange tree!
Dig it, dig it!
There's a couple, there's five of them.
How long is this game?
What are these quests?
I think we might need to do a part two.
What is that?
Battery for the yellow car?
Is this...is this yellow?
Is this yellow?
There's all good objectives on our screens!
Why don't they get so heavy to me?
They're being heavy to me!
Wait, but there's another...wait, Nimi, there's another tree over here!
Where?
Show me.
Follow the sound of my voice!
Oh, guys, do you see the guy in front of us?
Yeah, I see them.
Yellow car, I got two.
Okay.
What is the yellow car?
What are yellow cars?
It says five-hour game?
Holy moly.
Okay, we're at the three-hour mark.
Someone said we're only halfway.
No way.
We're halfway.
Is this an orange tree?
Orange tree!
Where's another one?
Yeah, I have something to do in like an hour or so.
Oh my gosh.
She's coming after me.
Doobie's over there.
Doobie found a lever.
This guy is like... Oh, this guy's an asshole.
Yeah.
Okay.
Doobie's alive.
Oh yeah, Doobie's alive.
Doobie found a lever is what she said.
I thought when we find the moon, we like, fire and finish the game.
He's not chasing you.
Well, he was, but...
Alright, we gotta... We gotta get the shovel back.
We gotta get the shovel back.
Shovel.
Shovel time.
These guys are aggressive.
I'm gonna go this way and check out one.
It's so scary.
Wow!
Come on, Dougie!
Oh, maybe...
I think we can.
Probably, I'll go check.
Yeah!
Is that useful?
We can get the shovel from the vending machine.
Yeah!
We can get it from the vending machine.
Okay!
Yeah, yeah.
Should I get it?
Yeah, let's rez, Dougie.
Wait, come back!
Because I thought he was friendly.
Why would you think anything in this game is friendly?
I don't know!
I just said hi to him!
I'm gonna go be a hero.
Are you gonna get the shovel?
No, I'm gonna try to drop this thing off.
Oh!
I don't know where it goes.
I know, I unlocked the door there.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, did you?
Yeah, you can go straight.
There you go.
I'm gonna dig this area.
Did we do this tree already?
Wait, we need a shovel.
Wait, I got the shovel.
Oh, you did?
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
What did Nimi do?
She's gonna go...
Try and activate the...
The...
Elevator.
Oh!
Yeah, the elevator.
Okay, as soon as we see it, activate it, we know she did it.
Whoa!
They're looking at us?
Nah.
I hear them.
There's a second goo door?
Okay.
I got it.
Wait.
Currently in use by someone.
Why?
I can't get it.
Oh, wait.
It might be in the other building.
That's why.
Hold on!
I'm getting the...
It's here, I think.
I think I shot and ran.
Maybe?
Or...
It's gone?
It has a gun.
Yeah, we have it.
Get over here.
Wait.
We have to wait.
Oh, no.
No, no.
You don't have to wait.
Just go.
I like how they're waiting in the elevator.
Okay, now we can...
Okay, now we can do it.
Okay.
Oh my god, three seconds.
Oh.
Hi.
Okay.
Alright, let's go, let's go.
Everybody, my chat lied to me.
What did they say?
They said that you needed the gun.
Yeah, she has the gun.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh.
Doobie, I think you're muted again.
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
We can hear you, we can hear you.
Yeah, we can hear you.
Oh, bridge.
Yeah, there's a bridge here.
There's so much panting everywhere.
Oh my goodness.
I know.
All the meow-meows.
That's what you call them?
The meow-meows.
I guess we're getting to the second floor of the annex.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
Oh gosh, I'm stuck.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm good.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That scared the heck out of me.
We're okay.
No, we're not.
We're not okay.
We're not.
How many times has it been?
I don't know if you've said it yet.
I can't stop.
That's me.
Okay, we need to find a corpse.
Oh, wait.
They're alive.
We need a fresh corpse.
Wait, wait.
Is it alive?
No.
No, she died.
Oh, let's get her back.
Yeah, get me back.
We can get her back, yeah.
Hello.
Welcome back.
I got got by an eyeball, so be careful.
Okay.
Wait, what's the...
Wait, the electrical box is here?
Why don't you want to place a fresh astronaut corpse here?
Well, we can do that.
Oh.
That could've...
Where'd you have to get the...
It could've been me.
Oh, like you have to die to it?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
You've been dying right here.
Oh my god.
Eyeball, eyeball, eyeball!
Eyeball, eyeball, eyeball.
I warned her about the eyeball.
Oh gosh, I'm stuck.
I was going to go into the hole.
Go near me.
I was going into the hole.
Holy...
Gaming tap here.
I'm lost.
Uh oh.
I don't know.
I think maybe Tab has accessed the map.
Cause I have no idea.
I think it's Tab.
Was there a body?
Like a fresh one?
Us.
Can I let him in by opening the door?
Oh!
Oh, that was close.
It's like the other guy, but he's quiet.
I can only hear them very spangly.
They're like...
Is that a fresh body?
Oh no, wait.
That sounds...
Oh,
it's the safe one.
Oh my god!
You were gaming!
You were gaming so hard!
Guys, guys, guys, guys, watch out.
Be careful.
Eyeball.
I think that eyeball comes from out here, actually.
Uh oh.
No!
Shot?
No way.
Oh my gosh, I'm stuck.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, no problem.
She was...
Oh!
Okay.
Why is he up here now?
Guys, come back.
Oh yeah, we'll come back.
Okay.
Oh.
The other guy was a pain in the ass.
Not gonna lie.
The guy with the sword?
Yeah.
Here he comes.
Oh.
Oh no.
I thought he was.
No!
Oh no.
She's gaming wh...
She doesn't know, he doesn't know...
Why?!
Wow.
Is that the trick?
Yeah, that's the trick.
Emoto!
Oh my gosh, this is a good one.
He won't get me!
I'm dancing!
Ah!
He didn't like my moves!
What is that?
Oh, then we got got too.
Spin to assert dominance!
It's okay.
I'm not a strong dancer.
Oh my god, there's so much stuff.
Wait, it's just the same caps that I found before.
Okay.
Well, first we need to find a fresh corpse.
Guys, I should have a...
...appointment with my throat doctor soon, hopefully.
For now, I chugga chugga these...
...sirups.
To
be...
To be's famous last words.
To castle?
Guys, I think it's the corpse that's like shown in the little hole.
And downstairs?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh!
Should we go downstairs?
Maybe.
There's also other stairs.
I don't know which one is the right stairs.
It could maybe drop down.
I don't know.
This guy sucks.
The sword guy.
Oh, it's locked.
Wait, I know a way to get down.
I saw it.
Oh!
It's not locked.
It's fresh here.
No.
Yeah, cuz we watched that guy die, remember?
Oh, yeah!
Oh!
So he's fresh.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
He's ragdoll.
Holy ragdoll.
First, okay, we...
Woo!
Let's stop there.
Turn around.
Where are we?
Oh, okay.
Right there, right there.
Yeah, right there.
Oh!
Oh, we just made...
We made a new worm.
Oh, freaky!
Oh, Dopey!
Let's go save.
Her sacrifice is not in vain.
Oh, what the fu...
Oh, shoot.
Come on, man.
No!
I wish I weren't!
Oh, I'm so dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, shoot!
I'm juking him!
Come on!
Stop!
Ah, oh, oh!
Oh, you're dead!
Oh, it's okay, Jesus!
No!
Oh, no!
Are you alive?
No, I'm not dead!
No!
That's not what I asked!
Oh, no!
Oh, I got so trapped, yeah.
Are you alive?
Nope.
Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Yeah.
Push, push.
Wait, the capsule, the capsule.
Push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push.
Okay, go, go.
Okay, I'll lead the way.
This way, this way.
It's in a corner.
I think the guy's still downstairs.
No, no, he's upstairs.
He's by the safe point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's walking over to the left.
I'm pushing.
Oh, the eyeball.
Eyeball, watch out.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
It's okay.
I'll die.
We're not.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, I did!
Now, Doobie!
Doobie!
You can juke this guy, which is...
I'll distract the guy, I guess.
No, no, don't distract him.
Doobie, don't distract him.
Doobie, doobie, don't distract him.
Why does she think we're alive?
Please!
Oh, this is what... Oh, it's in like a little cubby.
Oh,
he's nasty.
Get eyeballed.
Bad timing.
That was such bad timing.
I was such... Okay, I... I... I was like, oh, Doobie's so smart, and then you got ran over by the eye.
I was like...
Doobie!
Doobie, no!
Fine!
Fine, fine, fine!
Okay, I'll distract him, I'll distract him.
Yeah, what was distract him?
What is...
Great distraction, Doobie!
Oh my god, I got a second hand cut by Doki's stupid body.
Are you kidding me?
Thanks a lot, Doki.
You couldn't just... You couldn't just die on your own.
I'll wait for the eyeball to pass.
There it is.
Doki obstructs even in death, it's true.
Yeah.
Body blocked.
It's like she wants me or something.
Gosh.
Oh no, oh no, no.
Oh my god, that was so close.
I spoke too soon.
Oh my god, this part is so tough.
It is.
Okay, he's still downstairs.
I feel like there's gonna be a way to cheese it.
Are we sure he's downstairs?
How do we push it out of the corner?
Oh, oh, you can.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
I see him.
He was by the save point.
Damn it.
Where are we going?
I don't know.
But I saw it last over here.
And the worm...
Nimi, watch out!
Oh.
I think she got caught by something.
Bring it downstairs?
Is this downstairs?
We're going to bring us back downstairs.
Here you have.
I'm lost.
I'm scared.
Where do I go?
You got this.
Here?
Maybe?
Red line?
Okay, I'll follow red line.
Wait.
Now how do I get to it?
Ugh.
So in here?
I'll bring it in here?
I hear...
panting.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Oh, we need one more though.
What is this?
Oh, I can just sit down.
I can just take it easy.
There's one more right here.
What?
Did we see another one?
I think there's another one over here too.
Yeah, there's two more!
We need two more!
How did we say?
Oh, she's right underneath us.
I guess that's why.
Oh, I said okay.
I looped him.
Okay.
He's still downstairs.
Wait, but there's only...
There's two more that we need.
Where's the other two?
I don't know.
I saw...
He's not downstairs.
I saw where the other one is.
I saw one.
Wait, he's not downstairs anymore?
No, he just chased after us.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
Where are the other two capsules?
He's coming downstairs!
No, he's coming upstairs.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh, my god.
Okay, what's over here?
Any more capsules?
Maybe there's a...
Oh, it's this area!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the third floor!
What?
I don't remember.
Any capsules around here?
Oh, are those downstairs?
Wait, are they alive?
We could try.
They're in the hallway.
Oh.
I saw...
There's one on this floor.
There's a door that was...
Oh, okay.
Okay, so I'll try and lead the other...
We'll try and lead them back.
Oh, gosh, I can't see.
Why is it so dark all of a sudden?
I didn't...
He's right here.
Oh, my god.
Are you kidding me?
Don't keep our daylight with that looping tech.
Oh, my god.
I can't loop because I'm being chased by Mimi.
Okay.
Doobie's looking for the...
Oh, Doki died.
Nice looping tech.
Good job, Doki.
He jumped up here.
Come on.
Oh, no.
This guy...
This is so tough.
Holy moly.
Yeah, it does have a difficulty spike, right?
Sheesh.
We need dynamite.
No kidding?
Not it.
Not three, they're gone.
They've been turned into some kind of giant worm.
It's not crawling across the floor.
It's a nightmare.
Get us out of here before it's too late.
Oh.
Oh, I thought you were...
I thought it was going to turn down here.
This squad is in panic.
No one would just say it's not...
I don't think I'm...
Stop.
Ah, ah.
Yeah.
Oh.
Doobie.
Ah,
true one.
Make them go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you can crawl through there.
They're gonna make them go.
Oh, oh, oh.
I can't sing at all, but I can hear the...
Yay!
Yay, guys.
Guys, I...
Maybe we should save this for part two.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
We'll...
We'll be back something...
Yes.
We...
This is like...
3-0.
We keep dying.
We keep coming back.
I know.
We cloned ourselves so many times.
We're Mickey 500 at this point.
We're Mickey 500.
Oh, TV, you're muted, I think.
Oh, hello.
Sorry.
Hello.
You're good.
Okay.
I'm down to do a part two of this.
Me too.
Yeah.
We're halfway, apparently.
We're halfway.
I wanna release the moon!
The moon!
Yeah!
We gotta...
We gotta save the moon!
Yeah!
Thank you for joining me in this collab, guys!
Thank you.
Thank you!
It was fun.
A lot of fun.
Yeah!
We'll get them next time.
We'll get them next time, boys.
Wait, what was the Brickdancing one again?
Oh, I got it, that's three.
Three?
I'm gonna hear these sound effects in my dreams tonight.
Thank you for your help.
Thank you everyone!
Thank you everyone for joining us!
Yeah!
I had a great time with green and yellow today.
That was great.
Alright, we'll figure out when to play part two.
Sometime, yeah.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Alright!
Alright, I'll see you guys later!
We'll get to move next time!
Yeah!
Yeah, me too!
Alright, I'll see you guys!
Bye bye!
Save?
Oh.
What?
What are you...
What is this?
We need to have out, you can't hear anymore.
Yeah!
Oh, Stokie should save, because she's the host.
Thank you guys for watching!
Wait, wait, wait, we're 15 seconds.
Oh yeah, save, save.
We're on mute.
I hope the host can do it again.
It's still loosened.
Hold on.
No, we can't hear anything.
Oh!
Gosh, these sound effects.
Get me out of this hell.
Ta-da!
Okay!
Peace!
Bye bye!
Bye!
I guess if you exit, it's fine.
I'm kinda scared.
Kinda sca- Oh!
Don't see that.
Oops.
I think I just...
messed everything up.
Um...
Well guys, I have a secret to tell you.
I never was in a space suit.
I never was in a space suit to begin with.
I...
I don't know if you can tell.
I wasn't lying.
I was role-playing.
Love seeing the green and yellow.
Yay.
We'll be today.
Good luck with your throat doctor appointment.
Yeah, I had my...
I had...
My regular doctor appointment today.
And I was like, Hello!
Um...
First of all, they were like 30 minutes late.
And so I was like, Well, this is not good.
I hope I can make it to my collab.
And then they were like...
I was like, Hello!
I want to go to the throat doctor.
And I talk a lot.
And...
Um...
Throat hurt!
And they were like, Okay.
And it literally lasts...
Probably four minutes.
Not even.
Three minutes.
Me being like, Can I go?
She yaps.
Your honor.
And thus, we must...
Why am I punished for...
For...
For yapping, huh?
Why am I punished for yapping?
That'll be $50.
Close.
Close, unfortunately.
But yeah.
So...
Then I can just schedule my next appointment.
And then I get the tube.
And if they have...
If they take pictures and show me...
Which they should take pictures.
But if they...
If they give them to me, I will show you guys.
Um...
I'll say...
Here's your warning.
Three, two, one.
Minto's throw!
Blah!
For free?
Yeah, for free.
Hopefully it doesn't look so bad.
What if it's like...
Covered in nodules.
And they're like...
They're like, yeah.
It looks bad.
And then I'm like...
Okay, I'm gonna show my chat now.
Because I've healed up pretty well, I feel...
I don't think it will...
Like...
Be so bad that I need surgery.
But I think the extra month off...
Or less streams will be good.
And then hopefully...
If they give me some medicine or something...
That would be good too.
I hope.
Think of the content.
No vocal cord parasite.
Your throat will be beautiful?
You think so?
Flutter my eyelashes.
Twinkle, twinkle, twinkle, twinkle, twinkle, twinkle.
What if there's a baby in there?
I hope it gives me a middle finger.
It's just like, yeah, I've been...
Bing-bonging on your vocal cords.
Suck it, loser.
Remember me though?
Tough times never last.
Only tough people last.
We need a vocal cord live stream.
That goes a little outside my comfort zone.
Yeah, this was such a fun collab.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching...
Us be silly, silly.
And...
I'm gonna finish my dinner now.
My sandwich.
It was so fun!
I'm so glad that...
Actually, this is my first time collabing in-game with Doobie.
So...
Really happy that I could...
Finally, actually collab with her.
And...
Of course, I'm always...
Happy to collab with Nimmi.
And...
Doki behaved today.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I head out.
And...
I will see you guys...
When I see you next...
You mean Freddy?
Freddy?
Freddy!
I'm ready!
Otsumita!
Thank you, everybody!
I didn't even welcome you guys in.
I'm so sorry to the maid cafe.
Well, I will say...
And I will say...
Kittu rashai!
Ojo-sama!
Wait, did I say...
Ojo-sama before?
Ojo-sama!
And...
Goodnight.
Otsumita!
Bye-bye!
Thanks for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
Bye-bye!
The mic is hard!